Õpetaja: Nii, ee, screen rekraad. Ime vist. Aa, okei, ee, Korra Paneme rekla pausile.
Õpetaja: Tuhat viisteist.
Õpetaja: Kolmekümne.
Õpetaja: Tänan, Screen. Kaks. Jälle. Ee, ma mõtlesin, et ee teeks. Algust. Võibolla praegult sellise kerge kordamisega.
Õpetaja: Ja just selles mõttes Niiöelda, et, ee,
Õpetaja: ee, Võibolla vaataks viimase kahe päeva kokkuvõtet. Mida see niiöelda ai on niiöelda teinud.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd ta näiteks täpsem ka. Ee, sellepärast, et need kaks päeva on niimoodi, et Koodinäited on siis need
Õpetaja: ee, mis see niiöelda koodibaasis on, et iga kord, kui ma teen, näeb välja mingi niukene, onju mingi kole asi, Ja ega ta väga hea ei ole. Nagu väga hea kvaliteediga, Sest et ta vist ei oska seda eesti keelt ikkagi väga hästi, eriti Kui on inglise keelsed terminid vahepeal, vahepeal või mingid numbrid või asjad,
Õpetaja: et, ee, iga päev ma nüüd siis saan öelda talle, et ole Hea tee. Transkrip on olemas, et tee lihtsalt nagu kokkuvõte sellest. Aga tee kokkuvõte koos õppematerjalidega. Kui me, vaatame esmaspäeva ja teisipäeva no Tegelikult, Reede. Tegelikult me enam vähem alustasime voega,
Õpetaja: Aga need teemad on siin kaustas toks all Teil kõigile kättesaadavad mateerias ja siis niimoodi kuupäevade järgi nad siin,
Õpetaja: et kui võtta näiteks esmaspäeva ette,
Õpetaja: vaatame meeldetuletuseks siin. Ee, millest ta siin räägib?
Õpetaja: Ee, mis on Meil nagu kõige tähtsam. Ee, Siis hakkame pihta siit.
Õpetaja: Ee, failiviited. Ee, koodi rida. Bla, bla, bla blabla, bla, blabla. See meid ei huvita. See On see nii? Ja Andmed
Õpetaja: Templeid näitab kasutajale midagi. No nii,
Õpetaja: noh. Kui ei usu, siis ee. Koodibaas lahti. Ee, võtan lahti. Näiteks selle mida me oleme siin putitanud. Template osa on see visuaalne osa, on nii?
Õpetaja: Ei, valeta meile. See asi metsaots teeb. Tegevusi
Õpetaja: on on ju Dato hoiab ühist sisu
Õpetaja: Ühine sisu nende kahe vahepeal olete nõus.
Õpetaja: Kui kasutaja kirjutab vormi, siis liigub info andmetes. Kood muudab andmeid. Siis template reageerib sellele template data Methods nagu meie blokid.
Õpetaja: Ee, koodi näide. Selles repos. Aa on siis kohe näha et
Õpetaja: meil on siin erinevad muutujad. Näiteks input username ja Alert Error. Message see siin. See siin viitavad data bloki muutujatele. On see arusaadav?
Õpetaja: Siin on interaktiivne element. Siin on niimoodi et ee, see Kastikene Niiöelda username saab selle sisu, mis on siin ja vastupidi, et kui see sisu seal input Boxis muutub, siis see peegeldub ka selles Muutujas on siin kellelgi veel küsimusi. Selles
Õpetaja: mõttes päris analoogias on nagu lao riiul, kus nii müüja kui ka kassapidaja, võtavad, sama kaubaseisu,
Õpetaja: ehk Siis toimetab üks ja toimetab. Teine Ja nende kahe vahel on lao riiul noh mingi niuke analoogia.
Õpetaja: Ära näpi Tommi, Otse, Ee, kõlab natukene Pedofiilselt. See väike Tomtom on ju? Ära näpi Tommi otse. Lase raamist renderdada, et kui me seal alguses tegime Aa dokument, kett, element by Id. Mäletate seda? See on läbi, Domini elementide katsumine
Õpetaja: Ee, siin on ka see, et ma isegi ei hakka teile näitama, kuidas tegelikult ka Voes on võimalik näppida elemente natuke paremini kui lihtsalt Id de all.
Õpetaja: Aga me ei, soovi seda pigem. Teha Sellepärast me soovime, et lihtsalt Andmete pealt. Asju rennerdatakse.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui proovid koodis käsi saada, Toomi elementi, võib juhtuda, et seda elementi pole veel renderdatud aga ma näitan ruttu ära. Ma saan näiteks mistahes elemendil. Näiteks sellele inputkastil usern. Ma saan talle referentsi külge panna. Niuke asi nagu rehv.
Õpetaja: Ee, Kurat, ma ei mäleta, Kuidas see käis üldse kuidagi? Niimoodi? Ma saan talle panna näiteks, et see on ee, user. Nii
Õpetaja: input
Õpetaja: ja ma saan seda referentsi kasutada kuskil koodi osas. Mul ei ole plaanis seda jätta. This Ee, this punkt refs.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ta peaks juba pakkuma Mulle seda siin.
Õpetaja: Aa, User, name input. Näete. Sa saad koodis. Tegelikult, kui sa väga tahad, sa saad viidata Htm elementidele. Aga probleem on lihtsalt seda, et juhul Kui mingil põhjusel see osa ei ole renderdunud. Siin on mingi V If või mis iganes ja sa viitad mingisugusele koodilõigule, millel on referents küljes. Aga lõppkoodis seda ei ole olemas.
Õpetaja: Kood hakkab viitama justkui asjale mida pole olemas, et, ee, see on see mõte vaata, et you Are Asking for Trouble.
Õpetaja: Vanasti. Ma kasutasin seda lahendust, kui ma ei saanud aru, et et tegelikult seda tuleks niiöelda vältida, et kui seal Tekib kohti, kus muud moodi ei saa. See on Fine. See on täiesti okei.
Õpetaja: Peast. Oskan kohe näite tuua.
Õpetaja: See see kastikene Mingi, mis teeb. Vaata Soovid mingit faili? Lisada endale sinna. Noh, upload. Ida, mida iganes sul on Nupukene Selectfile. Vaata, vajutad nuppu, Mis juhtub Ee siis Explorer tuleb lahti. Vaata, Windows. Vähemalt tuleb see aken lahti, et mine vali kuskilt endale Artist fail ja siis niiöelda võta see endale Sisu
Õpetaja: See sisu kätte saamine Kõik on Tip Top. Veel Referentsil pole. Aga kui on niimoodi, et sul on mingi fail juba niiöelda Selected siis näitab ka. Vaata, et sa oled selle faili valinud. Mingi faili nimi. Mis iganes,
Õpetaja: kui sa tahaksid seda ära tühistada, vaata et kuule, et Ei, Siin ei ole nagu mingisugust. Seda Noh, mingi nupuga. Clear, nagu. Vaata või Refresh. Mis iganes, et mõte on see, et sa olid juba faili valinud. Aga nüüd sa soovid, et juhtub see, et see fail ei ole valitud, siis see element näitab faili. Vaata, mida sa viimasena valisid,
Õpetaja: kui sa programmiliselt soovid. Näiteks seda nuppu niiöelda muuta, et ee, et. Kuule, et
Õpetaja: ei ole mingit faili valitud Cancel, vaata, et Nagu Ära näita, et siin on mingi faili nimi,
Õpetaja: Siis seal ei saa enam niimoodi hakkama. Et Databloki andmete pealt see kuidagi saaks manipuleerida, et ta muutuks nagu tagasiseisu. Seal on pigem see, et sa paned referentsi sellele. Ee, sellele niiöelda nupule. Niiöelda siis külge sellele input ile Inputfile. Aa,
Õpetaja: paned referentsi külge ja programmiliselt. Sa saad siis seda nagu tagasi, Nagu, et on kohti, kus me ei saa muud moodi, aga See on nagu väga erandlik, et see, mis me siin üritab rääkida, on seda, et ära ära hakka käsitsi
Õpetaja: näed? Kui kui proovid seda mingit asja otse käivitada, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, Võib juhtuda et seda elementi pole veel renderdatud. Tingimus peidab selle ära. Viitad millelegi, mida hetkel ei eksisteeri Põmm viga.
Õpetaja: Aktiivne raamistik teeb sama töö turvalisemalt. Kui andmed ütlevad, et midagi peab olema siis Voe joonistab selle ise. Väga halb tee kood otsi. Äkki pole olemas head tee. Muuda andmeid. Kohe otsustab midagi uutada.
Õpetaja: Koodi näide. Valeri terror ei lähe käsitsi Tomi peitmajega näitama, ta teeb Seda andmete järgi näete see siin. W. If error message.
Õpetaja: Kui Rms Id siis on, tühiste ring, siis see ja seda ei näidata. Kui Sellel on sisu. Siis näidatakse Wave
Õpetaja: Päris annoloogiline. See on nagu liiklusvoor. Töötab sensori järgi. Ise mitte Keegi ei jookse käsitsi tuld sisse välja lülitama. Seda saab ka ju teha, onju? Noh, ja sa saad tellida selle vähemalt nupust, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga muidu ju enamus foorid ju ma Ei, tea, autodele panevad ju ise automaatselt, onju? Keegi käsitsi ei reguleeri Vigu ei teki,
Õpetaja: bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, blabla.
Õpetaja: Mis me siis veb? Seitsmes, jätka. Blogin View Arendust. Bla bla, bla. Vormi väljad, nupp valideerimine. Mida iganes. Koordinäide
Õpetaja: Ee, Oota, mis siin. Veel on
Õpetaja: juhib vahede joonduste ja laiuste loogikat. Aa Õpetaja rõhutab, et layout ei tasu ehitada. Suvaliste pikslitega annab, annab mõistlikud ehituskivid justify content Center Margin, Potom kolm. See aitab hoida vormi ühtlase paremini hallatavana
Õpetaja: konteiner Pro call input id pealkiri. Ja nii edasi tuleb tuttav ette. Vaata klassid
Õpetaja: Cssi. See teeb selle Dvs. See teeb selle Rivi Colliks. Nad mängivad omavahel. Kokku
Õpetaja: See siin ütleb, et kõik ee asjad, mis selle rea Sees on joonesta keskele joonde keskele. See ütleb, et kogu laiusest, mis on tol hetkel sellele saadav mõttes jaga kogu laius kaheteistkümneks Praegult. Kasuta Kolme osa sellest. Üks neljandik
Õpetaja: Margin Bottom.
Õpetaja: Peale seda heederit. Hoia järgmist asja minust. Ee, niiöelda kolme võrra. Jälle mingi mõtteline osa mitte Pikslid
Õpetaja: Data tagastab ühise andmemudeli. Õpetaja seletab pikalt, et data ei ole lihtsalt suvaline koht muutujatele, vaid meetod, mis tagastab Objekti selgitus, See tähendab, et Data ise on funktsioon Ta tagastab objekti. Selle objekti väljad on need reaktiivsed väärtused, mida template ja meetod omavahel jagavad.
Õpetaja: Data on oma olemuselt Meetod meetod, mis tagastab. Tagastab andmeobjekti. Skeem, Data, return, mudel, objekt. Näete, objekt.
Õpetaja: Kõige lihtsam viis Objekti teha on New objekt asemel lihtsalt loogilised Sulud Bioscript. See nii töötab. Siin on juba objekti. Süntaks, onju? Võti Väärtus võti, väärtus
Õpetaja: koodi. Näide on sama. Muster on siin username login, Response, bla, bla, bla. See siin on ühe kihiline, onju?
Õpetaja: Ühekihilil on lihtsalt üks rida. Ee, string, string string, See on omakorda objekt
Õpetaja: Võib olla ka nii päris analoogia. Päriselu Analoogia. Sa nagu koostad enne tööalgust vormi, kuhu kõik väljad on ette nimetatud. Noh, ma ei saa aru sellest analoogiast. Aga enamvähem käib kah Ig model
Õpetaja: seob sisestuskasti input ja muutuja kahes suunas. Selgitus B mudel, tähendab, et kui muutuja muutub, muutub kast.
Õpetaja: Kui kast kasutaja kirjutab kasti, muutub muutuja kahtepidi sidumine.
Õpetaja: See eemaldab tohutu hulga käsitsi Ee, koodi kirjutamist. Skeem input, vee model on seotud Data user name näiteks Mis iganes. Repos on olemas, mõlema välja jaoks.
Õpetaja: See on nii.
Õpetaja: Ee, päris on nagu tahvli andme tahvlil ja andmebaasis Olev number on ühe ja sama nupu. Ma ei tea, mida iganes seal ei äpi. Siin.
Õpetaja: Ee, restveebiteenused, frontend I ja Backendiga
Õpetaja: pärast vormi Osa minnakse ee, suure pildi juurde. Mis üldse on Veebiteenus. Miks frontend peab sellest aru saama? Selgitus, põhimõte on lihtne. Frontend saadab Hdp sõnumi Backend töötleb selle. Backend tagastab vastuse Hetkel meil Backendi. Pole Meil on Stop Light, Kes lihtsalt meie sassi teeb.
Õpetaja: See ei ole ainult andmete Küsimine vaid kokkulepe selle üle, mis rajal sõnum liigub.
Õpetaja: See on Backendi poole peal.
Õpetaja: Mis andmed kaasa lähevad? Mis kujul tuleb vastus tagasi. Mäletate Sväger, mis peegeldab lihtsalt automaatselt, genereeritakse meie koodibaasi koodibaasi pealt. Niiöelda peegeldus, et mis veebiteenused on, mida tootab sisse, mis rajale, mis tuleb tagasi, See on kokkulepe.
Õpetaja: On kokkulepe. Me peame mõlemad seda teenust kasutama. Sellisel viisil skeem. Frontend saadab sõnumi. Back end saadab vastuse. Frontend kuvab tulemuse Saate aru
Õpetaja: Koodi näide.
Õpetaja: Ee, login kaasa. Lähevad nimelised parameetrid username väärtustega.
Õpetaja: See on päris analoogia. Ohoh, restoran menüü. Vaata, mille peale tema on välja tulnud. Mis näide see on? Nagu restoranis. Menüü järgi tellimine. Sa Ei, ütle lihtsalt midagi süüa, vaid kasutad kokkulepetut vormi. Noh, kokkulepitud vorm on? Menüü, on ju? No mulle see mingi onju.
Õpetaja: Parameetreid Viteproxi hoiavad töö liikumas.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin räägitakse väga praktilisest töövõtet. Frontence Saadab Ee, Frontence saab edasi areneda ka siis, kui backend veel puudub.
Õpetaja: Aga kuidas meil on vaja? Keegi, kes vastab,
Õpetaja: teeb siin. Ee, Stop Light teeb siin Võltserveri rolli. Defineerid Urli. Defineerid sisendit, Defineerid näidisvastused. Frontend saab juba oma tööd testida. Stop Light Is Mina olen selle osa ära teinud Juba
Õpetaja: Defineerin Urlid. Defineerin teenused, Defineerin vastused. Võimalikud variandid.
Õpetaja: Väga Oluline osa on ka. Proxy Frontence saadab näiteks api kaldkriips,
Õpetaja: aga viite suunab selle taustale Õige serveri või Moki vastu, saate aru? Ee, meil on niimoodi, et meil. Tegelikult me saame see kogu kompott Html failide ja asjadega esmase Päringuga saab meie Brauser saab selle kätte.
Õpetaja: Seal on andmeid puudu. Nüüd päriselus on kaks lahendust. Ta peab hakkama neid Andmeid Back enda servereid paruma. Üks variant on see, et otse lähevad kohe sõnumid. Back end ile. Kohe lähevad. Otse sinu arvutist lähevad nüüd Back end Ile sõnumid
Õpetaja: Me saime Saime Html I kätte. Nüüd on. Tuleb välja, et siin on andmed puudu. Kõik on seal programmeeritud, et nüüd palun hakka tooma andmeid igasuguse erineva lõigu jaoks ära, onju Nüüd, Kas need sõnumid lähevad otse
Õpetaja: meie Back and serveri vastu? Või noh, see on ka võimalik. Siis sa pead selle tegema kõik või Mis on niimoodi? Ta saadab need sõnumid tagasi. Tegelikult, Ee Front and serverile. Frontend. Server saadab selle edasi
Õpetaja: vastab. Frontend saab selle kätte ja Frontend saadab jälle tagasi meile nagu, et on vahendaja rollis. Mis see teeb? Nagu lihtsaks on see
Õpetaja: Peame ainult ühes kohas kõik ära programmeerima. Põhimõtteliselt,
Õpetaja: et me ei pea nagu see on selles mõttes, et. Ee, kui midagi muutub meie serveri Seadistustes. Me läheme oma Fronti kuskile ja teeme mingi konfis mingi muudatused. Meie backhand server. Nüüd asub sellisel aadressil ja automaagiliselt. Kõik jälle toimib,
Õpetaja: Et, ee, selles mõttes nagu, ee, on see niukene lihtne lahendus. Mõlemad lahendusel. On omad plussid ja miinused.
Õpetaja: Aga see töötab selles mõttes niimoodi Meil Ja töötab ka enamus projektides. I would say ee skeem. Frontend
Õpetaja: saab sisse sõnumi api
Õpetaja: Nüüd Vite Proxy saab aru. See on nüüd See seadistus siin. Teeme siis korra selle lahti. See viite Ee seadistus on siin.
Õpetaja: Öeldakse, et kui mingisugune sõnum algab niukse asjaga,
Õpetaja: siis palun Saada see sellile vennale see, sest, et meil endal ei tohi olla ühtegi urli, mis hakkab kaldkriips Appi sest kui see on mõeldud frontend I serverile, siis see on ilma selleta. Kui see on mõeldud backend serverile, siis hakkab sellise urliga. See on põhimõtteliselt see metodoloogia, kuidas ta aru saab.
Õpetaja: See on see väike muudatus. Vanasti sai ta natukene teistmoodi ka hakkama. Aga ma juba siis mõtlesin, et väga huvitav, et kuidas Ta saab aru, et kumb kummale see on mõeldud? Kas on Frontile mõeldud? Või? Vanasti ei olnud nii tehtud.
Õpetaja: Kõik, meie vaatame korra oma Login View D. Ka ruttu. On ju
Õpetaja: korra natuke tagasi, et ta läheksin õppematerjali. Siis lähen Login Viewse,
Õpetaja: et meil on siin see sõnumi Saatmine nagu mis meil on. See on meil eraldi kohas. Oota, ma panen veel.
Õpetaja: See on meil siin selles. Ee, Service all
Õpetaja: Siin on Sõnumi saatmine. Back end ile läheb kaldkriips aap.
Õpetaja: Ja kui meile Fronti tuleb sisse mingi sõnum api, siis ta saab aru, et see ei Ole meile,
Õpetaja: see ei ole meile. See tuleb edasi suunata. See tuleb kellegi. Browser Isse suunatakse koheselt edasi. Kuidas tänu sellele kohale sõnumid, mis tulevad sisse. Api ei ole see, et hakka renderdama. Nüüd mingit vaadet.
Õpetaja: See on nüüd see, et saada see edasi. Kas siin on küsimusi?
Õpetaja: No ei, ole väga tore.
Õpetaja: No lähme edasi.
Õpetaja: Skeem. Front Frondile tuleb. Sõnum saadab siis Stop light ile Edasi Ee Stoplight annab näidisvastuse koodi näide.
Õpetaja: Noh, see sama, koht, mis me just rääkisime.
Õpetaja: Päringus saadakse query Parameetrid need. Lähevad sinna urlile otsa
Õpetaja: sa. Nagu filmivõtetel kasutatakse ajutist rekvisiiti Enne kui päris ja see valmis saab
Õpetaja: mida iganes. Väga tore. Ee, enne päringut valideeri vormi. Hoia positiivne D If blokis, bla, bla, No me Ei, jõua nüüd kõike läbi Käia, Kas te nagu näete, et tegelikult teie peaksite neid läbi käima?
Õpetaja: Te peaksite neid läbi käima, teil ei ole kinnistanud. Need mõtted veel. Te peaksite siin. Te peaks iga rea. See, et ma ei räägi, kui te igat koodirida veel täna Nagu ei tea,
Õpetaja: aga siis teie missioon peaks olema see, et kui te hakkate nüüd järjest võtma neid, te peaksite isegi tagasiulatuvalt minema, umbes Sinna kohta, kus ma alustasin tegema. Reede vist oli see reede, onju? Te peaksite sealt maalt hakkama, uuesti neid asju nagu vaikselt vaatama ja proovima, siis mõelda. Vaata, et mida see õpetus sulle tegelikult räägib.
Õpetaja: Kui Sul, on mingeid küsimusi mingeid asju, siis Copy Based, Väike lõik, Pane endale. Sinna Cloud I, vaata ja ütle. Kuule,
Õpetaja: Võid võtta siit ülevalt selle referentsi Selle faili kohta ütled? Näed, Copy Bad Reference from repositori. No ma panen korra praed siia.
Õpetaja: Noh, Sul on kohe rada sellele failile, ütled? Kuule, ma jäpin sellest
Õpetaja: nii ja. Ja sa võid kohe öelda. Täienda seda Sama nagu juhendit. Täiesti Sama juhendit. Mul on küsimusi veel Niukse asja kohta. Palun Lisa juurde. Põmm ja. Ja näed, see on niimoodi. Vaata, kas ta parandab seda kohta, millelt sa aru ei saa. Või teeb eraldi sinna alla midagi juurde?
Õpetaja: Ee, saate. Siis vaadata, Kui Te töötate need asjad läbi,
Õpetaja: ee ja hoiate niimoodi ennast järjel, siis Teil on kogu selles viru. Harjus on raskem, lihtsam nii öelda orienteeruda,
Õpetaja: et. Ee. Noh, see see vajab aega. See vajab aega. See vajab aega niimoodi, et te minuga tutvute nende asjadega, Aga nüüd see Vajab nagu niukest aega, et veits Vaatate neid asju üle. Vaata ja siis nagu enda jaoks. Päriselt üritate selgeks mõelda. Ja palun väga, seal on igal pool need ajaviited juures,
Õpetaja: et kui kui tema selgitused nagu ei ei kliki kohe ära, on ju No mina, otsin siis õige minuti ülesse sealt ja vaata korra. Siis see lõike üle. Vaata, on ju et kui. Kui on asi, mis sind kõnetab ja sa saad, aru,
Õpetaja: me ei liigu edasi. Aga kui on midagi, nagu Mis sa mõtled, et tegelt ma ikkagi ei saa aru, mis siin räägib, siis See tuleb selgeks, teha, sest et praegult, mis me vaatame, on nagu kogu aeg mingi A, B, C asjad. Põhimõtteliselt A, B, C,
Õpetaja: et Ee, vot ongi seda, et kõike pea ei ole prügikast. Kõik ei pea detailideni pähe õppima. Kui see on mingi Niukene asi, mida võibolla Mingi korra aastas või kaks kasutad siis ei oleks nagu mõtet nagu asja nagu pähe tuupida. Vaata, on ju? Ja nagu mõelda,
Õpetaja: aga nagu Mingisugune Basic mõte, et, noh, kiitmine, lahutamine kümne piires nagu, võiks ikka inimestel selga olla vaata. On, ju et, ei peaks hakkama seal mingit kalkulaatorit välja võtma, et see on nagu sama mõte, et teil on siin mingid asjad, mis, ee, on kindlasti vaja ära õppida.
Õpetaja: Okei, aga Lähme edasi, Ee, Ma lihtsalt tahtsingi näidata seda, et tegelikult seda päris hästi teinud. Ja Nüüd, kui ma teen igapäevaselt neid ka siis tal Need näited ja asjad saavad olema kõik nagu Õiged, kui vaadata, võibolla siin seda viimast
Õpetaja: ee viimast videot. Seda siin juba alguses ütleb. Vaata, Et, Ee,
Õpetaja: selles õppematuralisatsioon. Teemad päris näidetega failidest. Bla, bla, bla, Noh, Pretty Good,
Õpetaja: et, ee nüüd me oleme järjel, et ee, selline süsteem võiks toetada.
Õpetaja: Ee, tehke heaks üks fetch. Vaadake, siin on need õppematerjalid Valdavalt Ongi tegelikult koodi mõttes Midagi ei ole muutunud. Ärge muretsege, tulete Järgi Siis kui tulete, onju? Koodi mõttes ma midagi vahepeal ei ole teinud.
Õpetaja: Ee, kuhu me jõudsime Otsapidi selle loo kinni ka on sisuliselt, Tegelikult peaks olema nüüd Aa, tehtud.
Õpetaja: Võime natukene. Ee, Aa, veel. Võibolla üks asi ka. Siis Kuvama Alerti. Vaata, user Id ja role name I veel ei ole. Ee, siis võibolla teeks selle asja ka ära, onju? Proof of concept.
Õpetaja: Ehk mõte on. Pange serveri ka. Pange tee Ka Ee, et see, et kui me läheme sellele ee, lehele
Õpetaja: ja meelde tuletuseks ka, me tegime selle hookuspookuse sinna sõnumi saatmise kohta. See,
Õpetaja: Kus kohas meil on see? Aa. Kõik Service Id appi. Service Id.
Õpetaja: Võibolla Isegi peaks selle ümber nimetama Api Service is, et kuidagi seostad seda ainult back end iga
Õpetaja: teekski Esimese asjana teeme siin Rename. Lihtsalt oli väike Click siin Service Peal Shift F, kuus
Õpetaja: api services, ehk Siis selle kebab iga.
Õpetaja: See On Back end Back end. I kutsutakse tihti nagu Api S.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, kas siin Ee, tuleb ka midagi.
Õpetaja: No Ta ütleb, et mingi viga vist on kuskil sees vä.
Õpetaja: Ahaa, okei, Ee. Ma saan aru mis on probleem.
Õpetaja: Ee, viited, mis tal on Siin Impordis. Ee, mitte siin, vaid selles. Näiteks.
Õpetaja: Ee, see. Ta ei saanud aru refaktoreerimist.
Õpetaja: Ta ei muutnud seal seda. Selle faili rada muutus Ta enam ei ole. Kaldkriips Source Services, vaid on Api Services. Kui me teeme korra nüüd lahti. Log in view
Õpetaja: view D alt, kui Aitage Control Shift. Enne pange L ja Vee. Otsige see Login View niimoodi ülesse.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin on importosa. Näete, mul muutus. Nüüd Ma arvan, Et võibolla tal ikkagi hetk võttis aega.
Õpetaja: Selge?
Õpetaja: Ta Tal ta nagu korra korra. Nagu justkui ütles, et ma viitan ikka veel, Vaata selle Service Ile nagu siin all Minul korra, nagu, Vähemalt ee,
Õpetaja: ee, serverit käivitades. Ta viskas nagu mingi alla Mingi vea, mis tegelikult ei vasta tõele. Nüüd ongi ikka okei. See oli mingi anomaalia. Lihtsalt korraks võttis aega natukene, onju, nii et. Aga ma teen nüüd lahti, vaatan, kas Nagu päriselt ka
Õpetaja: mäletate, me tegime siis Login Services, niimoodi et.
Õpetaja: Ee, tegelikult. Vaata, meil on siin Niukene osa, mis ee, lõpus enam ei Pea olema see osa siin, Headers.
Õpetaja: Ütleme sellele, Ee, stop Light Ile, et. Kuule, kui kasutaja logib sisse nimega admin, siis anna mulle selline Vastus Admin, exempel, error. Siis ta annab error I Ja siis on customer. Või mis iganes, siis ta tegelikult annab selle ma nimetaksin üldse ka customer iks ümber.
Õpetaja: Nii mõte, on selge? Vaata, et, ee, Kui me sisse logime, meil on see ära tehtud, et kui ma panen Admin,
Õpetaja: siis ta nüüd logib mind sisse. Kui admi.
Õpetaja: Kui ma panen siia error, siis ta annab mulle selle vastuse, et vale kasutajanimi. Parool
Õpetaja: Stop Light iga väikene manipulatsioon.
Õpetaja: Ja me tahame siis teha seda, et kui juhul, kui meil on admin
Õpetaja: ja me tuleme siia sisse või Või mis iganes muu nimi, siis ta on customer. Siis siia tuleb lihtsalt väike alert ja ütleb, et sinu user Id on see ja Too vaata.
Õpetaja: Mäletate, tegime ka selle Protection I ära.
Õpetaja: Ee, niimoodi, et kui me tegelikult oleme välja logitud, aga keegi üritaks läbi Aa Urli läbi urli tulla rajale, mis nõuab sisse logimist.
Õpetaja: Ee, noh, jälle need vennad siis mängivad, tantsivad mingid bolkad. Kas on mingisugune Minecraft vä
Õpetaja: Aa, Okei ja ja Okei, sain aru. Nii, ee, et niuksed asjad meil siin praegult on, siis on ju. Ee, siis lähekski siis sinna Login. Vabandust, mitte.
Õpetaja: Ja teeme, niimoodi, et. Ee. Niipea kui siia lehele tuleme, tuleb ette alert. Noh, just rääkisime korra siin. Ee, oli Madises, Sinu nimi on? Ju
Õpetaja: Aa, siin Madisele. Selgitasin. Ee, seda Before. Kui see see niiöelda komponent laetakse. Ma tahan et käivituks Alert. No see on ju mingi tegevus. See on script, onju?
Õpetaja: Aa, siis, kui ma tulen praegu siia alla, otsin, kus tata blokk lõppeb. Panen siia koma.
Õpetaja: Ee, Panen siia, Mounted.
Õpetaja: Mountaid on meetod. Näete, seda saab käivitada. Seda käivitatakse meie eest. Tähendab, oleks muidugi parem ee see väikene vahe, et before on niimoodi, et ee. Enne kui ta üldse hakkab templateid renderdama, siis ta jooksetab selle Mounta. On, see, et ta ka nagu selle template Osa nagu
Õpetaja: renderdab nagu ära Ja siis. Käivitab. Ee, mingid tegevused
Õpetaja: siin. See vahe ongi, see, et kui siin mingi referentsi vii kasutajaks, ütleks et ma ei tea, see hind. See header näiteks on rehv. See on korra vaatamise koht.
Õpetaja: Ee, ref, Et oletame, et siin on referents Ja siin on mingi nimi.
Õpetaja: Mingi nimi Ref
Õpetaja: Siis Before on nüüd täpselt see asi. Vaata, et see asi ei ole absoluutselt veel renderdatud, Kui ma siin koodis ütleks Dis punkt, Refs,
Õpetaja: punkt,
Õpetaja: Mingi nimi ref. Siis See kood annaks mulle juba vea. Sellepärast Before Mount tähendab, et Enne kui üldse templetit hakatakse siin uurima ja tegema, siis juba käivitatakse see kood, Mounted. Seevastu oleks niimoodi, et
Õpetaja: kõigepealt ikkagi see, nagu mingil Kujul renderdatakse ära ja siis käivitatakse See saate mõttest aru, et siin ongi see Nagu see on see ohtlik, on see otse näppimine Ee võib igast jama hakata tekkima pealgi. Me ei soovi seda niikuinii. Me soovime, et enamus meie veebilehest ikkagi renderdub lihtsalt andmete põhjal
Õpetaja: nii aga Siin me võime. Noh, ta võib olla.
Õpetaja: Noh, las ta. Olla. Vahet pole ee. Siia võib siis kirjutada praegu Alert,
Õpetaja: et see saab koodi kohe kirjutada. See ei pea nagu see. Ei defineeri meetodeid. Mis iganes koodi siia kirjutad, see kohe käivitatakse. Koheselt käivitatakse.
Õpetaja: Mina panen praegu siia, Message I näiteks Ee, user Id.
Õpetaja: Ahaa, ma näitan teile ühe väikse up. Triki Ka kursus. Jah,
Õpetaja: No see on prügikasti kaup. Ee aga Põhimõtteliselt küll. Jah, Selles mõttes Sa võid. Võid teha niimoodi ka
Õpetaja: nii alert.
Õpetaja: Ma panen niimoodi. Siis User Id
Õpetaja: panen. Kool on pannud ühik Panen plussi. See võib ka vaatamise kohta olla, aga. Aga tegelt võiks selle korra ära teha. Taaskis tegelt on nõutud ja nüüd viitan sellele muutujale, Mitte useridi, vaid
Õpetaja: kuidas.
Õpetaja: No mis? Me rääkisime Madisele ka, et mingeid sisse peab kasutama. Iga kord, kui sa siin selles kritiplokis toimetad, Kui sa viitad databloki muutujatele või mingitele meetoditele, mis on siin selles,
Õpetaja: siis viitad sõnaga?
Õpetaja: Noh, praegu juba peaks niimoodi olema et kui ma Login siia sisse.
Õpetaja: Tuli see user Id. Kui ma teen see Refresh I, tuleb, et käivitatakse kohe. See koodilõik.
Õpetaja: Need koodid, mis siin käivitatakse Maanteede osas. Need käivituvad automaatselt ja tuleb, siis, ee, kui sa räägiks
Õpetaja: nii. Aga teeme nüüd. Aa,
Õpetaja: teeme nüüd siis ka selle, et me Saame kätte siia. Lisaks user. Id le ka.
Õpetaja: No Jällegi Kus kohas meil? Kas ma just panen nüüd kinni? Vist enam vist ei saa Mingid vennad hakkavad siin. Keegi või?
Õpetaja: Too sõna.
Õpetaja: Ta tüüp tegeleb kunagi. Lihtsalt ulata.
Õpetaja: Ee, kujuta ette, kui kallis see maja restaureerimine võiks olla,
Õpetaja: No päris hea väljend on nii kaua seda teinud. Tegelikult siin juba eelmine aasta nad siin toimetasid fassaadi kallal. Ma ei taha ette, ma Ei, kujuta ette,
Õpetaja: kas niuksed majad vist on mingi muinsuskaitse ka Või selle mingi reeglitega, et ei saa Tahaks panna endale mingeid normaalseid tänapäevaseid lahendusi nagu mingisugune ja mingid muud asjad. Siis öeldakse pakettaknad. Ja
Õpetaja: see on nagu see, et kuule,
Õpetaja: et sa oled nii rikas inimene, et Sul on vanalinnas Ee, korter, et sa võid endale jääkuubikuid osta või midagi,
Õpetaja: et ee, kui tahad jahutada Ee, mäletame, kuidas selle ee, selle User Id. Niiöelda sai Outservice. Meil on eraldi. Fail on nii? Et on kõrval siia.
Õpetaja: Meil on eraldi fail. Me ütleme, et user Id Tuleb läbi selle meetodi. Get log in user.
Õpetaja: Ja me tahaksime teha Tegelikult, ee, nüüd midagi taolist nagu Get Role.
Õpetaja: Me tahaksime, et me Ei ole võimalik ka rolli alati saada sealt Local Storage ist kätte.
Õpetaja: Ehk me peame tegema ühe uue meetodi, mis lõpuks tagastab Siis põhimõtteliselt Mäletate, millest ma räägin? Mis See, mis see Local Store öelge. Tee mulle parem. Mis asi see
Õpetaja: on? Seal hoitakse siis praeguses sessiooni andmeid.
Õpetaja: Ee, tegelikult. Siin hoitakse üleüldiselt. See ei kustu üldse ära. Ee, vanasti Taaskis oli mul Session Storage. See oli see, et niipea, kui paned, Tab I kinni. Läheb. See kõik. Informa mida iganes siin on. Vaata, ma võin panna siia mingi info.
Õpetaja: Ma panen praegu selle kinni, siis See kaob ära.
Õpetaja: Tulen, ee uuesti. Igaks juhuks Tulen uuesti. Täiesti nullist.
Õpetaja: Ma olen inspekt.
Õpetaja: See oli F. Kaksteist oli, onju Inspekt, Tulen siia, Application,
Õpetaja: siis. Ee, need asjad kaovad siit ära. Ma just valisime. Mingid andmed ei ole niimoodi. Siin on see, et kirjutan siia Aa väärtusega Üks on ju?
Õpetaja: Noh, no ei, Õnnestu.
Õpetaja: Näed, see on siin. Ma panen selle. Kinni. Teen uuesti lahti.
Õpetaja: F kaksteist Teen uuesti lahti.
Õpetaja: Ma Ei tea, kas ma vajutasin. Muidugi sei ma entrit vajutasin. Vajutanud, aga. No siin ta ongi. Ma ei näind kohe. Ta on teises järjestuses,
Õpetaja: Siis kui näiteks Browser is. Paned, et vaata Näiteks siis
Õpetaja: või siis, ee. Või siis programmiliselt. Sa oled mingil veebilehe. See Käib veebilehe juurde. Vaadake, see on kaheksakümmend Kaheksakümmend üks. Kui ma olen näiteks mingi Apollo kino. Vaatame karuvi pärast.
Õpetaja: Ma teen siin selle sama lüke,
Õpetaja: mis mul siin on. Näete, Apollo Kino all on mingid niuksed. Asjad on nii?
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, mis siis nüüd on, aga need on tulnud nagu Programmiliselt, Kuidagi on ju loomulikult mingi midagi,
Õpetaja: et see. See ei kao ära,
Õpetaja: kui see midagi nagu mõistlikult ka tundub mida, nagu tunneks kuidagi ära. Võibolla
Õpetaja: mingisugune account Id. Ma ei tea, mis need siin kõik võivad olla, on ju?
Õpetaja: Kas ma olen. Oota, ma vaatan korra, ma Panen korra kinni. Kas ma olen sisse logitud? Ka Ma olen est. Ma Korra ma vaatan. See Muidugi võib nüüd urliga olla. Ma panen Hing.
Õpetaja: Näed, see tuli juurde. Vaata, et see seda ei hoia ta meeles praegu kuidagi. Aga ma korra võib pulli pärast vaadata, kui ma. Kas Ta jätab meelde ka? Vaata, ma panen. Ee. Noh, see tuleb pulliga.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tulen kuskilt Urliga tagasi siia, siis ee, ta ikkagi jätab selle urliga meelde.
Õpetaja: See on nagu keeleseadet. Ee, vaevalt siin on sellepärast, et see, on teistmoodi lahendatud. Okei, nii see selleks,
Õpetaja: Aa, siis Meie tahame praegu siit saada kätte sellest. Ee, see, mis nagu siis Ei, kao ära kinni panemisega. Me tahame saada siit kätte. Nüüd järgmisena Seda
Õpetaja: roll name I ja väärtust Siis me teeme siia Authentication Service seal ühe uue meetodi
Õpetaja: get all. Name.
Õpetaja: Aa, nüüd, minul on mõte, Vaata, tegelikult ka rolname iga, et kus iganes kohas ma tegelikult seda. Aa, rolname I. Niiöelda küsin, siis See eeldus on see. Vaata, point on see, et kas tal on midagi returnida,
Õpetaja: Et kui seda meetodit. See on nagu see, et kui sa programmeerid, sa pead natukene mõtlema, Vaata, et kuidas seda võidakse kasutada. Ja kas mingis, et küsimus on see, et kui mina kuskil küsingi, et Roolnei me seda soovin kasutada,
Õpetaja: Siis kas ma olen üldse sisse logitud
Õpetaja: et jällegi on see. Vaata, et kui ei ole sisse logitud, siis ma tean, et ju seal Session Stores. Is. Mingit väärtust pole. Vastab tõele
Õpetaja: ja siis Tähendab, seal on jälle nagu see sama asi. Vaata, et, ee, aga siis ju Tal ei ole midagi tagastada. Ja kui ma saan ka null I, siis ma pean sealt, kust ma selle välja pärin ja saan nalli, Siis ma pean vaatama, et kas ma sain midagi või ei saanud. Ma tahaks samasugust Protectionit teha, nagu ma tegime sellega
Õpetaja: et kui sa Sisse ei ole logitud. Siis saadetakse üldse et. Kuule, et sa raist
Õpetaja: teeme Niukse lahenduse. Vaata, et meil ei ole mõtet küsida mingit väärtust, mida ei ole võimalik saada. Ja kui sa juba seda küsid,
Õpetaja: siis tähendab seda programmiliselt. Midagi toimub siin niimoodi, et nagu sul sul tegelikult Sa ei saa siit saada midagi kätte. Ilmselt sa ei ole sisse. Me teame, kui sa neid väärtusi kätte ei saa. Sa ei ole sisse logitud või? Õigemini vastupidi. Kui sa ei ole sisse logitud, siis ei ole mõtet küsida, kui sa ei ole sisse logitud, sul ei ole mõtet seda küsida, on nii?
Õpetaja: Nüüd mõte on see, et meil on vaja täpselt samasugune kontroll teha, et kui sa Aa ei ole sisse logitud. Siis saada kasutaja Nato autorised lehele.
Õpetaja: No see, mis me vist ennem nägime, onju? Siis sai logimata. Üritad minna Kaldkriips Htms
Õpetaja: hetkeseisuga Ta saadab kukemu, Peaks selle tegema, sest ma ei ole sisse logitud oma arust Või olen. Ma olen praegult. No ma login välja.
Õpetaja: See mõte. Vaata, onju? Siin taustal üritatakse küsida user Id D, Aga siis on nagu, et.
Õpetaja: Noh, ta näitas null korraks, aga vahet pole see See, et ta näitas korra, lihtsalt on see, et käivitus see alert ja ta lihtsalt oli väike väärtus null.
Õpetaja: Nii me tahame sellest sama asja teha, Aga nüüd minu küsimus on, mis te arvate, kui me teeksime seda samamoodi? Paneme selle koodilõigu siia. Tuleb sama asi, on ju Kui ei ole sisse logitud,
Õpetaja: Mine, Nato, Oota, raisk, vaata sisse. Aga mis mõtted meil peaks tekkima? Aga kui me näeme, et meil on siin nagu ühes Samas Coopis on kaks korda seda täppi pealt. Sama koodi
Õpetaja: seitsmes.
Õpetaja: Ei,
Õpetaja: üldse ei ole vaja panna, Sest et päeva lõpuks Vaatame, üks tahab saada. Peab tulema. Return, onju? See peab tulema. Siia Peab tulema mingi string. Ta peab tagama tagastama lõpuks mingit rolli nime. See on eesmärk,
Õpetaja: aga siin on probleem see. Vaata, et meil on täpi pealt samasugune kood Rida Realt tähtajält kaks korda.
Õpetaja: Mis mõtted siin Võiks olla nagu sellepärast, et see. Me toodame koodi juurde, Et kas nüüd tuleb veel mingi kolmas asi? Sama,
Õpetaja: kuidas? Kas kutsume selle meetodi nimega.
Õpetaja: No aga kas me tahame saada siis ta return? Ib ka midagi. Vaata, siis ta tagastabki meile ka mingisuguse user Id. Ja kas Siin selle user. Id ga. Meil pole midagi teha,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, sa, ee. Kuidas Rem oli? Onju? Remi mõte oli nagu praegult. Seda, et Me kutsume praegult siit meetodi. Ee, vot seda meetodit. Aga. Aga mida siis see meetod tagastab? Meetod on nimega Get
Õpetaja: ja siis Void ei saa määrata. Vaata, me ei kirjuta Type Script I. Aga me selle return I saame alati ära võtta, on ju? Ei ole, Siin on midagi midagi muud, mida ma tegelikult Otsin. Siin see praegu taaskasutus mingisuguse imeliku loogikaga, nagu ei töötaks. Vaata, onju, et kasutaja ei saa midagi aru, aga meil on endiselt see mure. Vaata, et meil on üks sama koodi lõik.
Õpetaja: Tähtähelt. Üks Sama koodiline lõik on erinevates meetodites kirjutatud Juba kaks korda.
Õpetaja: Tingimused ei ole probleemid.
Õpetaja: Noh, voh. Noh, mille ühe? Mis sa ütles, et teeme neist äkki mingisuguse ühe meetodi
Õpetaja: nimeline koodilõik, Et selles mõttes, et kui meil tekib nagu niukene olukord, et meil tekib tublikaat kood, See peaks kohe meil peas trigerdama, Aga mis siis, Kui ma teeksin sellest ee nime sellest koodilõigust nimelise koodilõigu. Ja me saame mõlemad seda kasutada. Vot see on See õige lahendus.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, kuidas isegi teeb. Seda jätamegi meelega. Jätame meelega selle sama niimoodi. Selle koodilõigu siia niimoodi. Uuesti. Ma ei tea jaavast ta saaks nüüd aru, on ju,
Õpetaja: kui me ütleksime, et me võtame selle osa siit
Õpetaja: Nii kui me võtaksime selle osa siit ja ütleme Control alt, m, et tee Sest eraldi meetod Vaatame. Kas ta on piisavalt smart. Et Ta saab aru, et see sama koodilõik on siis ka siin, Ta peaks meile pakkuma, et Okei, me teeme nüüd nimelise koodilõigu. Aga kas sa soovid seda igal pool siis ka kasutada? Kus on täpselt sama koodilõik juba? Vaata Control alt. M.
Õpetaja: Vaatan Top level üks samm alla. Vaata, et see tuleb ka kuskile. Siis sisse.
Õpetaja: Ee, okei, Siin te vist nii hästi aru ei saa. Nüüd mis on selle meetodi nimi? No mida me põhimõtteliselt teeme? Mida me. Me peame nüüd natukene mõtlema nagu mingit niukest. Natuke niukest ümmargust. Nagu hägust. Natukene nime, aga siiski täpselt. Vaata,
Õpetaja: mida me sisuliselt teeme. Siin selle koodilõigu sees. Sest See koodilõik see See meetode nimi ei tohi valetada. Ainult
Õpetaja: meetode nimi peab kaile nagu ütlema, mis ta teeb. Aga meil on selles mõttes nagu väga imelikud Tegevused on ju, et vaatame, et kas kasutaja on sisse logitud. Ja Kui mitte, vaata, siis. Me saadame ta kuskile mingi lehele, et Your Nato autorise.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd me peame panema nagu. Kuidas me äri loogiliselt kutsume. Nagu seda olukorda. Vaata, et mi mis siin, tehakse,
Õpetaja: ei ole Päris see
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et. Ee, see meetod. Kui sa vaatad praegu. Vaata, me peame keskenduma, et sellele ma korra panen. Skape, Onju, Te peate mõtlema sellele nime välja
Õpetaja: ei saaks. Panna Sellepärast login staatusega. Sind ei ole, midagi, et mida see koodilõik teeb? Ta Vaatab, kas sa oled Ja kui ei ole, siis saadab nagu sind kuskile mujale lehele.
Õpetaja: Verify juba on nagu lähemal, Aga
Õpetaja: kuidas? No see on juba nagu ma Ütlesin, et me soovime midagi natukene hägusemat. Vaata, on ju, et see on täpselt nagu nüüd see. Noh, ta. See ei valetuks, Onju
Õpetaja: Ee, See oleks väga okei. See oleks väga okei nagu meetodi nimi. Aga siis, kui hakata mõtlema nagu mingi koodile et meetodi nimi peaks olema lühikene, aga samas nagu täpne. Valetada ei tohi on ju siis? Tal on natukene natuke pikk On minu maitse, eks?
Õpetaja: Ja, Ja tegelikult ta Ee, ikkagi ei ütle. Igas kontekstis, nagu me tahame. Nagu anda talle nagu mingisugused sõnad, mis on natukene kuidagi üldisemad. Ja nüüd ma tutvustan Ma vaikselt tutvustan neid sõnu. Vaata, aa, mis saab niimoodi? Kasutada kui on asju vaja asju natukene kuidagi hägusena hoida, aga siiski anda idee edasi, et mis seal nagu toimub.
Õpetaja: Sest alati saad sisse vaadata, kui meetodi nimi, nagu ei ütle. Nagu päris täpselt. Ära. Redirective, on ju Aa, kui meetod ütleb sisuliselt ära, mis seal toimub, aga jätab natuke häguseks siis sa saad alati sinna sisse vaatama minna, aga ta ei Valeta, see on kõige tähtsam.
Õpetaja: Ee, üks sõna. Mi? Mul on mõned sõnad, mis mulle meeldib kasutada. Aa, kui on mingisugused laused asjad seal. Aa, kuskil siin seal midagi mingi olukord.
Õpetaja: Aga siin olukorras. Ma kasutaks sõna nagu välitäit
Õpetaja: Nii, ja mina teeks sellest meetodist. Control M
Õpetaja: toob Level üks alla. Mina paneks selle nimeks Välitä User is Loged in.
Õpetaja: Sest et seda, ta sisuliselt teeb. See on natuke potato Potato, et Siin võib ka mingeid muid asju kasutada,
Õpetaja: Aga kui ma tuleksin siia nagu
Õpetaja: Aa meetodisse, loeksin seda nüüd nagu raamatut Get lot in user Id. See on missioon
Õpetaja: Välitä User is loged in.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd ma näen, et me võtame siis Local Storesist. User Id
Õpetaja: get login, user Id. See on missioon. Vahepealne samm on see, et valida user is loged in.
Õpetaja: See võiks siis olla ka põhimõtteliselt niimoodi, et, ee,
Õpetaja: ta Ütlebki, et kui ei ole nagu sisse loginud, et siis võimeline,
Õpetaja: et selles mõttes siin. Ei ole nii tähtis minu jaoks tegelikult saada aru Aa, mida see täpselt tähendab? Vaata, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga ei oleks ka kuidagi valet tingimata panna ka nagu pikalt. Näiteks onju tõesti, et ee, Või midagi taolist, on ju.
Õpetaja: Aga põhimõtteliselt me teame, et siin on nagu sa välitäit. Mingisugune situation eeldab seda, et seal võib visata nagu Mingit vigu
Õpetaja: või midagi? Nagu kasutajaga. Juhtub nagu back endist. Nagu oleks see sõna otseses mõttes oleks mingi viga. Visatakse back end süsteemist, kui Me hakkame midagi valideerima. Siis see tähendab seda, et potentsiaalselt visatakse Vigu siin on sama. Vaata,
Õpetaja: mis ma nüüd tahaks teha, On ta nüüd ei suutnud automaatselt selle panna.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga sellest ei ole hullu.
Õpetaja: Siin selles. Me saame seda taaskasutada. Lis, punkt väliteid.
Õpetaja: Noh, miks ta ei Paku seda.
Õpetaja: Ee, Noh, ma ei tea, Ma kopin lihtsalt selle niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ja siin tasuks natuke. Nüüd sättida seda ka jälle neid järjekorda
Õpetaja: et See on Niukene üleüldine, mida kõik kasutavad. Vaata siis, me ei saa. Nagu siin on see küsimus, et oota, aga mõlemad kutsuvad seda välja, Et Kumma meetodi järgi Ma panen selle nagu elama. Kas selle või selle. Vaata aga, siis ongi parem, et pane ta juba alla, Vaata Kui ta nagu Share itad.
Õpetaja: Kui me vaatame nüüd seda lõpptulemust
Õpetaja: nii
Õpetaja: ja selle meetodini me peaks ka panema, Võibolla siis niimoodi pikemalt in Role name.
Õpetaja: Võibolla isegi sõna user juurde. Get log in user role. Name
Õpetaja: midagi taolist
Õpetaja: Ongi Peabki string olema, onju? Orienteerite hetkel stringi. Nüüd Siia lihtsalt kirjutame,
Õpetaja: Siis sul ei ole selekteeritud korrektselt. Kui Ee, kui ta ei luba sul. Control Ltm I näiteks
Õpetaja: siis ei ole selekteeritud, Kas, ee, mingi loogiline sulg on väljas? Mis iganes
Õpetaja: ma jätan välja, jätan selle. Jätan välja.
Õpetaja: Sa valid ainult puhtalt. Ee, selle osa
Õpetaja: Näed, Kui ma tahaks praegu teha sellest asjast eraldi meetodit, Ta ei luba
Õpetaja: Set of Statements are expression Sa Sa pead võtma täpselt nagu niukse Osa, mis nagu päriselt tehniliselt on ka võimalik ära tükeldada. Ma ei saa, nagu, et selle see osa koodist tuleb kuskilt mujalt meetodist, et Sa pead nagu olema
Õpetaja: blokist Blokini mis teine.
Õpetaja: Ma ei teinud üles.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: No ja nüüd saab samamoodi. Siis kes tahab juba läheb sinna. Ee, tekitab databloki samamoodi. Ee, muuta nime, roll name
Õpetaja: ja siis saab kutsuda välja Outservice punkt. Get
Õpetaja: login, user, roll, Name. Midagi teha. Vist
Õpetaja: Ehk lähete Atm s Usse?
Õpetaja: Teeme ühe asja juurde.
Õpetaja: Role. Name Outservice punkt.
Õpetaja: Gate Loged in user all. Name
Õpetaja: ja nüüd siia lehti saab lihtsalt juurde panna. See on niikuinii Prügikasti kaob Selles Mõttes Sa ei pea muretsema. Plussiga saab niimoodi edasi panna, et
Õpetaja: Role name võrdub pluss Oled this roll, Name
Õpetaja: Nii, mina eeldan, et see asi on juba läbi. Ma panen juba komit I ära. Kes tahab? Ee saab järgi tulla. Ma panen Feb Seitse Compliet
Õpetaja: Committe and buss.
Õpetaja: Võin siit kõrvalt vaadata. Ka Ee Töötab
Õpetaja: siit ee sisse Logimine kasutajanimi admin. Ma tean, et Teil user Id on? Üks parool on. Vahet pole, mis ma siia kirjutan. Parool Iks, User Id. Üks on tehtud.
Õpetaja: Ma võin veel taaski üle vaadata ja mõelda, kas kõik asjad on tehtud.
Õpetaja: Blogi sisse vajutamisel kontrollitakse, Kas kõik väljad on täidetud? Täida kõik väljad. Kui on Mingi error, siis Alert Danger ütleb midagi, mis võtab sisse Propsi message. Kui message on tühistring, siis alert ei kuvata.
Õpetaja: Bla, bla, bla, bla, Bla, edukas päring.
Õpetaja: Ee info saadestatakse. Session Storage Isse. No, meil on Local Storage Menüüs peidetakse ära Sisselogimine link ilmub. Link logi välja. Peale. Edukat sisselogimist suunatakse kasutaja
Õpetaja: liikumine, vaatajale Atm s lehele saabudes peab saama kätte.
Õpetaja: Noh, Me just panime ja kuvame seda, et logi infot on võimalik talletada. Ja vajadus on see kättesaadav ka teistele vaadetele. No, tõestasime selle ära. Jah,
Õpetaja: kättesaadav. Kui kasutaja on sisse logitud, siis sisselogimine nuppu ei kuvata. Selle Asemel kuvatakse logi välja No seda on kõik tehtud,
Õpetaja: et see on compliit.
Õpetaja: Sai läbi see jama. Lõpuks alles onju
Õpetaja: Noh, Login sai oma võiduka lõpu.
Õpetaja: Mis meemes,
Õpetaja: Mis me nüüd teeme, Kui taaskond tehtud.
Õpetaja: Täpselt õige. Kuidas päriselus. Teeme onju, et sa pead pilve minema. Request.
Õpetaja: Mingi ta vaatab ära.
Õpetaja: Ee, väiksed parandused. Kui midagi seal saab muuta. Testimine
Õpetaja: testi on ära testinud, ütleb. Nüüd võib
Õpetaja: et see toimub kõik pilves. Masters otsa ei saa, aga meie meie seda nii teeme
Õpetaja: nüüd, Merch. Im. Seda kutsutakse Merch Imiseks. Tööde kokku sulatamine, nagu et üks töö nagu läheb teise töö sisse. See saab ainult teha pull. Ee, nagu süsteemis. Nagu, et me saame tõmmata infot see tähendab, Seda, et me peame kõigepealt minema oma harule. Mina lähen oma õpetaja peale. Ärge palun tee mingi õpetaja peale.
Õpetaja: Ärge minge ka Masteri peale, Minge oma nime peale,
Õpetaja: kuna te olete vahepeal nüüd kõvasti tulnud. Nagu minule harudega, järgi, siis seal võib mingi konflikte toimuda.
Õpetaja: Aa, kui te Hakkate Merch ima?
Õpetaja: Mina ütlen, õpetaja Feb. Seitse,
Õpetaja: Merch. Ja nüüd Merch I juures. Te tõmmate alati pidurit ka. Vaatate, kas see kõnetab. Merch Õpetaja Feb. Seitse intu õpetaja. Päris elus näeks sa välja. Merch. Feb. Seitse into Master. On ju,
Õpetaja: et see töö läheb sinna haarusse.
Õpetaja: Minul Peaks see õnnestuma.
Õpetaja: Kui kellegil tuleb Ee, konflikt ette, siis tõstke korra käsi püsti. Võibolla korra. Vaatame
Õpetaja: Artur. Aa, sellepärast, et Artur on ka vahepeal järgi tulnud või mis iganes, et siin võib tulla. Seda Tegora Screenshire. Ma võtan enda Screenshire i stop i peale
Õpetaja: Aa, siis ma Näitan, kuidas me saame. Praegusel juhul mitte päris elus, vaid praegusel juhul, kuidas me saaksime asju väga, lihtsalt Aa lahendada
Õpetaja: Nii, Aa see nüüd on Merch Conflict ja tööriist. Üritab aidata sul seda teha. Korda,
Õpetaja: Ee, siit. Oota korra. Ee, Kus natukene venitad seda asja? Aa, just ülevalt Need kaks veergu. Vaata, selles kastis
Õpetaja: seal. Samas aknas. Vaatamine paremale üles. Vot vot vot. Ei, mitte nuppe, vaid veerge
Õpetaja: vot üle sul kolm veel. Vot nii. Aga kui sa teed natuke neid laiemaks, siis
Õpetaja: siis tema ütleb. Vaata, et nüüd on Niukene värk, et, ee, on Artur, See, Mille peal sa praegult oled. Ehk sinu master.
Õpetaja: Vasakul pool on master ja paremal pool on see, mis sa üritad sisse Merchida
Õpetaja: ja Nüüd põhimõtteliselt Fail faili kaupa. Sa saad otsustada, et mida sa teed.
Õpetaja: Juhul kui su. Sa juba tead ette, et sulle sobib see variant, mis tuleb sisse,
Õpetaja: et jääb nii nagu on seal, Siis oleks väga lihtne. See lihtsalt praegult. Aa, sissetulev. Comit on seal paremal pool. There,
Õpetaja: Sa saaks klikkida nupu. Accept. There on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga, ee, päriselus. Tavaliselt see nii ei ole päriselus. Nüüd peab otsustama,
Õpetaja: et kuidas see lõppseis jääb, et kujutage ette, et see Master
Õpetaja: on ju, kus teised arendajad on arendanud.
Õpetaja: Te ei saa öelda, et jääb täpselt, see, mis seal on, Sest et kuhu siis läheb sinu tehtud töö?
Õpetaja: Sa ei saa ka öelda, et jääb see, mis minu asi on ja mul küll ei sobi. Mis teised siia vahepeal tegid? Sest et siis sa kustutad kellegi tööpõist ära ja ütled, et jääb nii, nagu mina tegin, vaid Nüüd on hoopis see et sa pead hakkama siis vaatama. Nagu, et. Ee, mis toimub? Ma korraks võibolla võtan sinu
Õpetaja: kuuekümnenda. Aprillil, ma korra Räägin. Ee. Seda, et kuidas see lähenemine peaks olema?
Õpetaja: Lähenemine peaks olema niimoodi. Et Ee, topelt klõps, või Merch ja Merch või midagi ei Tee veel ei tee midagi. Ei ole niimoodi, et midagi otsustab. Meie nupud otsustavad põhimõtteliselt selle faili mõttes. Merch või topelt. Klõps teeb sama tee. Ta avab eraldi vaate
Õpetaja: peab vaatama. Tee selle nii suureks, kui ma vähegi saan. Siin ei ole niukest nuppu, millega seda teha. Ma Ei saa aru, millal nad selle oota. Jess
Õpetaja: Viis aastat võttis aega. Selle nupu panemine. Näete, et alati klassikaliselt pidid ise neid aknaid niimoodi suureks tõmbama. Seda on parem
Õpetaja: või Kuidas see asi toimib, on see, et see keskmine asi saab olema nii nagu sina ütled, kuidas jääb.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on alati niimoodi, et sul on kaks poolt. Ühel pool on Master päriselus. Kujutage ette, et te ei tea Mastrist mitte midagi, te ei tea, mitte ööd ega mütsi. Siis te tegelikult võite juba siit klikkida ja võtta. Nagu See on niimoodi, et näed, see pood on Masteris. Mingi image
Õpetaja: explosion. See on minu niiöelda pilt. Vaata nüüd, ma Näitan. Vaata praegult, kuidas see vahe ongi. Ongi niimoodi. Minul oli minu Hull oli Explosion Mingi, mis ma internetis leidsin. Nüüd, Ee, see niiöelda. Tuleb. Ee, see on Arturis sees. Nüüd vahepeal niimoodi
Õpetaja: siin. Aa, okei, siin ei ole. Siin on hästi, pisike vahe. Siin on see, et üks on reastatud kolme reale ja teine on tegelikult ühele reale. Aga tema Ei, saa aru seda. Vaata, see algseis oli tal erinev.
Õpetaja: Kuidas päriselus saab siis töötada on see, et võtate alati Masteri aluseks,
Õpetaja: sest Selle kohta te mitte midagi ei tea.
Õpetaja: Võtate põhimõtteliselt sealt, kõik, mis nagu on.
Õpetaja: Ja siis hakkate vaatama niiöelda paremat poolt, et mida teie Olete tegelikult nüüd selle arenduse käigus teinud. Siin on nagu üsna halb näide. Nagu, ee, sest et see, ei ole nagu päris,
Õpetaja: ee, siis Kui me jõuame jaavasse, siis ma näitan teile nagu põhimõtteliselt selle ära. Kuidas see nagu päriselus on? Mida teie peate teadma, on see süsteemselt saab alati niimoodi põhjaks. Võtate. Mis iganes,
Õpetaja: sest et seal on teiste tehtud tööd ja käsitsi, Hakkad siit niimoodi koodividade kaupa kasvõi vaatama, et Mida mina tegin selle arendusega siia faili ja sa kasvõi copy based selle. Kui siin oleks näiteks mingisugune alternatiivi siia juurde, lihtsalt ma saan teha. Sest see on ju, Noh,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, See mõte on see, et te ei tea Masterist midagi. Te peaksite teadma midagi endale
Õpetaja: keskel, Panete kokku ja siis ütlete. Apply,
Õpetaja: Ta ütleb seda, et ma pole ära markeerinud. Siin on niimoodi, et noh, siin ma nagu tagasi siin Ma, nagu. See on kaks varianti. Ignoreeri
Õpetaja: või pane siia niiöelda keskmele. Pane see nagu siiapoole. Põhjust on mõistlik klikida kõik. Ära, vaata mis, on maskeri pool, nagu siin on nüüd see, et. Kuule, kas pane see siia alla juurde
Õpetaja: või et ma olen seda vaadanud.
Õpetaja: Tema jaoks on nagu see, et kas sa oled kõike vaadanud? Kui sa ei viitsi kõiki neid asju klikida, siis kui sa paned Apply, siis ta Ütleb, et. Kuule, sa pole nagu kõike asju nagu näidanud. Öelnud, et sa oled vaadanud. Sa võid öelda, et tegelikult jääb nii, nagu siin keskel on. Ja siis on ju
Õpetaja: Siis tuleb järgmine fail samamoodi jälle. Sa peaksid siis vaatama, mis me teaksime, on see, et, ee, kui Master on meil siin vasakul pool laotud. Hetkel siis Master läheb igal juhul põhjaks.
Õpetaja: Teist asju me ei näpi. Aga nüüd näete nüüd paremal Pool näitab, et siin on mingid impordid.
Õpetaja: Siin ei ole, siin. Ei, no see praegu. Need kaks on identsed ju? Vaata, on ju siis Ma klikkisin siit kõik ära. Praegult. See keskmine osa on selles mõttes identne. Kuidas? Ta töötab, on see, et ta Üritab, Ma mõtlen korra tagasi
Õpetaja: siin keskel. Esial ei ole neid pooli. Vaata, mis on nagu nendes noortes
Õpetaja: siin keskel on. Niuksed, asjad, mille mille üle tal ei Ole probleeme aru saada, kuidas peab olema. See on ühisosa.
Õpetaja: See, Mis me praegu vaikimise sisse tulles näeme, on mõlema poole ühisosa ja siin on erinevused.
Õpetaja: Aa, näed, maskerid oli Mingi Niukene. Ma ei tea. Niukene. Ruudi.
Õpetaja: Enne.
Õpetaja: Nüüd lähme. Siin on see ka. Tegelikult on see siin Olemas on ju nüüd Neid nooretisi võib proovida. Saab alati samme tagasi võtta. On ju, et, ee, et kas ta paneb õigesse kohta või Mitte Vahel on mõistlikum teha niimoodi et, ee. Et, see on lihtsalt üks asi veel mis, on
Õpetaja: kujutad. Ette ainut või
Õpetaja: siis te näete ka ridu. Millal nad on tekkinud ja nii edasi teid väga. Võibolla see Masteri asi ei huvitagi, aga teid huvitab enda rea, mis te Olete teinud ainult, et nüüd, kui siin oleks praegult erinevad nimed, näiteks kujutame ette. Artur. Artur, Artur,
Õpetaja: Artur, Artur, Artur, Artur, Artur, Artur Artur, Artur Art oli kuupäeval juures. Teile ütles. Siin peegeldub ka enne, Nagu seda asja Nagu topelt. No teil on võimalik suht ruttu leida ülesanned viimased arendused, eks ole teinud? Kui te teete siit lahti. Aa, okei, seda siis ma tegin. Sa näed oma nimesid siin nagu mingi võõras koolis nagu põhimõtteliselt.
Õpetaja: Aa, need on need osad. Nüüd te saate proovida neid nuppe, kuidas ta teeb? Aga te peate olema valmis selleks, vaata, et Ta ei tööta perfektselt. No nägime mis juhtus. On siin kaks korda
Õpetaja: et tuli juba siit poolt. Ja
Õpetaja: error. Error tuleb siit. Ühisosa on alguses. Palun väga error aga see turakas paneb veel error siia. Saate aru, et siin tekivad nagu mingisugused asjad No importidega väga ei pea muretsema. Kui ma pärast läksin faili, vaid on, siis ta koristab ära. Asjad topelt,
Õpetaja: võibolla. Et Oo, ma ei tea, kas ta siin teeb.
Õpetaja: Ma julgeks neid kasutada. Ma pigem jälgiks. Vaata, mis toimub, nagu nii. Me ei näe,
Õpetaja: et nende lukkude kasutamine on nagu nii ja naa
Õpetaja: ja siin samamoodi. Ta kavatseb panna selle error ruutingu teist korda kui siit. Ma olen juba selle valinud, et igal juhul Master on kuningas,
Õpetaja: et väliselus. Sa Tegelikult hakkaksid vaikselt vaatama, nagu kus on minu tehtud kool. Kui see need Highlight Id ja asjad tõmbavad siin veest Kirjuks siis ülevalt saate valida. Vaata, et ee, vanasti sa sai.
Õpetaja: Aga võibolla siin vaates ikkagi ei saa muidu vanasti see maha võtta, et I atlines I like. Thirds
Õpetaja: üldse ei paku. Vaja.
Õpetaja: Siin ikka. Aga mis mis seal ikka, et ühel või teisel viisil on vaja aru saada, et kuhu asjad lähevad ja mis on lõppseis? No mina kasutaks siit selle rea ära. Nüüd siin on samamoodi. Panen need ruutingud siia juurde.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on jälle see, et siin läks tegelikult topelt. Kuidas ma päriselus tegelikult teen? On ikkagi pigem Copy Base. Kujuta ette, mini meetod,
Õpetaja: Sa tegid Sa pead ta kuhugi panema. Siin on terve posu igasuguseid meetodeid ja tuleks lihtsalt siit ja Võtaks. Control, C. Noh, ütleme need. Osa. Vaata, kus nüüd hakkab. Siit osast nagu tuleks. Nagu kujutan ette, ma lihtsalt leian oma meetodi ülesse, mis ma tegin.
Õpetaja: Ma lihtsalt tulen. Panen selle siia nagu ise õigesse. Rohkem.
Õpetaja: Vot niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ja kui kõik on hästi, siis ütlen, et kõik on hästi.
Õpetaja: Ee, front on natukene Raskem
Õpetaja: Siin on mingi. Aa, natukene. Rõvedam on. Aa, siis, kui läheb asja jaamaks. On palju lihtsam, et, ee see asi, et avatud ühte Sama meetodit
Õpetaja: on ebatõenäoline. Kui keegi praegu tuli see ette, vaata, siis te saate panna. Lihtsalt on, see on ju? See on sinu master, Vaata, sa seda ei taha. Mis Masteris on, vaid mis Sealt tuleb sisse, et teie, kui õpilased praegu teete, seda, te saate jääviin, nagu on Seal selles arendusharus.
Õpetaja: Te saate teha seda. Teil ei ole siis midagi karta? Vaata, on ju Aga päris elus ongi see asi, mis Te peate ise otsustama, Kuidas jääb. Sellepärast Kit enam ei tea,
Õpetaja: mis juhtus. Ongi see, et vaata, et kui Kip hakkab tagasi mörtsima mingit faili, siis ta eeldab, et see seis seal failis on Täpselt seal. Mastersil. Täpselt selline, nagu ta oli sellel hetkel, kui te haru võtsite,
Õpetaja: Saate aru, teil on mingisugune fail.
Õpetaja: Teeb hästi kitsaks. Vaata, nagu. Miks tal see probleem on.
Õpetaja: Teil on mingisugune fail. Panen on fail inglise keeles.
Õpetaja: See hetk, kui te auru võtate. Siin on kaks joon. Kaks rida koodi. Näiteks mis iganes ta lihtsalt sümboliseerib, see hetk, kui sa Lauru võtad, on Niukene.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd, kui sa siia samasse harusse, hakkad tagasi mörtsima, siis kui see seis on endiselt seal, täpselt sama siis Tema jaoks ei ole mitte mingit probleemi.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi ma selle haru niimoodi see fail alguses oli. Nüüd on tehtud kõvasti. Tööd on kohtunud, kui mitte. Ma teen selle nagu taustalt selle teise päästmise kõrvale.
Õpetaja: Ah? Ei ole eriti palju ruumi
Õpetaja: sinine, kast, Aga ma panen nagu
Õpetaja: need kaks faili. Oota, Alekseid on niimoodi. Me teeme väikse koopia.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd me toimetame Teeme koodi juurde.
Õpetaja: Nii kui ta praegu tahaks seda mersida, siis Tal ei ole probleemi. Vaata, tema. See algseisor oli Selline Tööd on juurde tehtud. Tema saab aru, et. No problem. Need read peavad tulema juurde. Isegi kui see read. Ta tuleb vahele, näiteks.
Õpetaja: Ta oskaks praegu selle ära lahendada. Siia tuleb ja siia tuleb ja siia tuleb, sest Algseis on selline. Aga kui nüüd keegi on vahepeal Masters
Õpetaja: mingisugust koodi ja nüüd tema tahab seda Merch I teha. Vaata, sest see algseis ei ole enam selline nagu haaruvõtmise ajal.
Õpetaja: Ja ta teab, et nüüd läheb nagu keeruliseks, Nagu, et ta Ei, ta, ei, ta ei saa, Nüüd ta ei tea, kuhu need uued sinised jooned peavad tulema. Ta ei saa ise otsustada. Lampi, et see tuleb. Nagu Kas nagu enne seda rida peale seda rida või see, kes sisse. Vaata, ta. Ta ei saa seda otsust võtta. Tema seis on muutunud,
Õpetaja: ta ei saa, Vaata Ja siis ta paluti sul. Vaata, Kuule, Master on selline. Või siis sa ütled Noida nagu onju. Parem, on noortega tõsta ja siis Sa hakkad vaatama. Oot, aga mina tegin selle ja selle ja selle asja hakuma panen. Ah? Näed, sobib, et paneme lihtsalt
Õpetaja: siia alla, saate mõttes aru. Vot see on nii lihtne. See tegelikult ongi. Aga selleks, kui ma päriselt keegi on kirjutanud sinna juurde, siis ma päriselt peaks hakkama süvenema. Mis ta kirjutanud on? Sa ei pea süve Vot. Sellest see point ongi.
Õpetaja: Selles ongi point. Sa ei pea süvenema. Mida Teine Tegi üli savi, mida teine tegi.
Õpetaja: Sa ainult keskendud sellele. Vaata, et sinna keskel sa esialgu paned. Nende noolekestega. Master, Master, Master Master, Master Master Master, vaata. On ju Sina seda ei tea. Ja nüüd sa hakkad vaatama. Teed selle teed näiteks lahti. Vaata, onju, et sa näed, Vaata, nagu Kus selles failis Sa näed kohe ära. Näiteks et, ee. See on selles konfliktis, et siin Ja siin on mingid uued kuupäevad Ja sinu nimi. Ahah, Okei, mina oma arendusega tõesti tegin selle meetodi.
Õpetaja: Mina, ma arvan siin tõesti kirjutasin niuksed, muutujad ja mis iganes, vaata, on ju? Ja nüüd sina lihtsalt ongi see sina ise. Lihtsalt manuaalselt niiöelda hakkad vaatama neid kohti, mida sina oled selle arenduse raames juurde teinud. Ja lihtsalt otsustad, et kuhu sa nüüd paned?
Õpetaja: Kui see on mingi jaava. No siis ongi see, et tegid juurde mingi public meetodi, Noh, vaatad, et siin on kaks Public meetodit. Otsid järgmise koha. Vaata, kui sa public meetodi panna on ju? Sul on siin mingid private Meetodid mäletad? Kohvimasin.
Õpetaja: Ee, kett. Cappuccino on nagu abimeetodil. Et siis ongi see, et sa vaatad. Ahah, ma panen oma kuskile siia,
Õpetaja: Nii, Noh, Masteris. Oled juba niiöelda põhjaks võtnud. Ja abimeetodid. Noh ma panen Kuhu siis sinna niiöelda? Alla. Vaata, mees teinud on vaid, Sa pead lihtsalt vaatama, kuhu sinu oma minule seda keegi kunagi ei õpetanud. Ja see Merch Conflict oli Niukene Night Meed nagu, ma ei saanud mitte midagi aru, aga tegelikult on siin väga lihtne.
Õpetaja: See on tõesti. Selles mõttes on väga lihtne.
Õpetaja: Sa ei peagi kesk, Sest et see on hirmuäratav, Kui sul lööb midagi sinna ette eriti retsiks, läheb. Siis kui keegi hakkab asju ümber tõstma. Ja avafailides Iga faili kohta on üleval package, Kus sa asud,
Õpetaja: Kus sina asud?
Õpetaja: Et kus sa oled? Kui keegi hakkab hullult tõstma faile asju ümber, vaata siis Refaktureerimise kohas on nii palju Faile. Kus see, Package name. Niiöelda seal muutub nagu rada muutub. Põhimõtteliselt. Kus sa enne see fail olid?
Õpetaja: Ja siis on nagu, et Sa. Sul tulevad ja alguses võib olla väga segane. Vaata, et sul on nii lihtsalt natuke raske aru saada, mis toimub, aga üli savi
Õpetaja: Lisavi on? Lihtsalt võta lihtsalt kogu master aluseks ja hakka nüüd otsima Sealt sealt kohast, kus ta näitab sinu niiöelda Haru
Õpetaja: sealt jäi lihtsalt see lahti ja vaata kuupäevi asju Ürita aru saada, et. Oot, noh, see vahel on lihtne, kui sa just midagi tegid ja mõõtsisid, vaata On ju? Sa just tegid sulle värskelt meeles. Aga võib ollagi, niimoodi, et mingi asi istub. Ee, selles järjekorras, et millal testimine hakkab, võib oodata. Sind Nädalaid on ju sul lõpus. Läheb endal ka meelest. Ära Vaata, mida ma tegin. On ju,
Õpetaja: Aga sa ikkagi saad võtta. Lahti ja vaadata. Oot, oot, ma ju tean, et mina pean keskenduma. Tegelikult ainult sellele, mis on. Mis on need minu asjad
Õpetaja: ja sealt sa Tegelt nad leiad ülesse. Annad kohe need read ära. Kas sinu nimi on taga? Mingid kuupäevad? See tuleb ka. See. Ma tean, et seerisa Nüüd peab kuskile siia minema. Lihtsalt otsi sobiv koht ja lükka sinna ja ongi kõik.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on nüüd ja peaks nagu muretsema sellepärast, et Klassikaliselt ongi see, et sa tegid juurde mingi meetodi.
Õpetaja: Seal ei ole selles mõttes. Nagu Seal on stiililiselt tähtis, et ta läheks mingi normaalsesse kohta.
Õpetaja: Nagu mingi järjestusmeetoditega ja nii edasi. Aga selles mõttes nagu Koodi enda mõttes. Näiteks seal on ülisabi Mis järjekorras sa need meetodid sinna topid. Pane tasku kõik plünaki alla.
Õpetaja: Paned sinna need meetodid, mis sinna juurde ongi. Kõik ainuke asi ongi see, et public meetod ei tohi. Järjest Ainuke asi, mis on Jaova nõuetega, on see, et kõigepealt tuleb, siis tulevad private meetodid, onju? Seda pead järgima aga samamoodi Otsi üks Vaba Slot.
Õpetaja: Kuhu sa paned selle public meetodi? Noh, viimase public meetodi alla paned uue public meetodi ja private meetodid paned meetodite alla. Vahel. Võibolla on muidugi mõistlikum natukene. Kuidagi mingit teiste järjekordade kuidagi. Raamatulikum oleks või nii On ju
Õpetaja: aga põhimõtteliselt ülisari ee. On natukene tähtsam sellepärast. Kui sinu liit tehtud kood on, et ee, Html kood minema Täpselt eelisse kohta. Ju
Õpetaja: Ta peab täpselt õigesse kohta minema. Ta ei mängi Kõikide nende teiste Timbide ja asjadega kokku. Vaata, sa ei saa seal panna. Paneb plöraki alla. Mingi uus nupp vaatab. Siis ta tuleb lehekülje. Alguses on lehekülje lõpus, on ju No või mingi kastikene
Õpetaja: et seal on natukene võiks olla nagu keerulisem, et sa pead natukene rohkem nagu sellele keskenduma, tõesti. Noh, selles mõttes sa pead keskenduma. Mida keegi teine on teinud, et natukene lihtsalt aru saada. Vaata, kuhu see sinu asi Nagu käib, onju,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, et, ee. Ja ma ütlen, et see võib olla kes väga, lihtne või See võib olla väga keeruline. Aa, Ja. Ja üks asi, mida te kahjuks ei saa, on see mitte kunagi, mida te ei saa, on see, et ma töötan kuidagi niimoodi, et mul ei tule Merch konflikti, sest et see ei ole teie enda kontrolli all.
Õpetaja: Strateegi ei saa kontrollida seda, mis failides teised tiimi Liikmed töötavad
Õpetaja: Nii Ei saa nagu. Hei, ärge siin midagi tehke. Nagu Mul on kaks nädalat aega.
Õpetaja: Ma ei, tea, mis Te teete neid Failid siin ei tohi teha midagi, onju?
Õpetaja: Võib juhtuda teistmoodi. Ka sina teed ühe faili. Paned sellele faili nime? Mingi kontroller. Keegi teine teeb Täpselt selle sama asja Kummalgi algseisundis. Seda faili polnud. Järsku põmaki Kaks faili. Vaata, on ju? No ei saa kontrollida seda, et, noh,
Õpetaja: et Me teeme mingeid sarnaseid asju ja ennem ei olnud mingit faile. Me mõlemad teeme. Peamegi. Tegema selle lõppkokkuvõttes saabki olema üks fail ja ja siis ütlebki, et. Kuule,
Õpetaja: ma ei tea. See on niuke Valees juba, et sa tahad ka suruda, nagu, et
Õpetaja: aga tore on, siis ma vaatan. Võtan tema oma põhjaks ja vaatan siis selle päris osa, nagu mis ma siin ei kustu. Vaata, sinu read tulevad juurde, ega? Vot See ongi see, et ega. Vaata, kui me teeme selle sama näite uuesti. No ma jäänud ühe korra veel
Õpetaja: Niimoodi ei ole, et tulevad Nagu samad read, et mõlemad on nagu sama asja teinud.
Õpetaja: Tema omad on nagu ees. Sina Paned samad asjad Fine Fine, kui see nii on. Aga kas siis vastab tõele? Kui sa võtad nüüd Masteri põhjas ehk siis see, mis tema tegi.
Õpetaja: Kui need on täpselt samad read, Mida sina tahad teha, Siis on väga Timm. Noh, see on olemas. Aga siis sa pead lihtsalt jälgima. Vaata, kas nüüd on veel midagi. Vaata, on ju. Kui üks ühele kattuvad, et see on mingi Niukene asi, siis üks ühele kattuvad. Väga hea,
Õpetaja: siis on olemas äkki on, Niimoodi, et nagu selles mõttes, see, mida see sait teeb, nagu nagu kattub. Aga see, kuidas see lahend on, on nagu eri
Õpetaja: praktikas. Seda ei ei juhtu mitte kuidagi, mitte mingi valemiga. Ja see see selles selles Organisatsioonis on väga suured probleemid kui, Arendajad hakkavad arendama samat ülesannet
Õpetaja: Et esiteks, nagu ütleb, nagu kelle taas see on? Nagu. Ja kes sellega peab tegelema, Teiseks. Kui meil ei ole, noh, seda pole. Siis Ongi see et teil on nagu mingi väga halb süsteem.
Õpetaja: Täpselt sama asja. Ei, nii ei saa olla. Sul saab olla mingisugune väike osa. Vaata aga, terve ülesanne ei saa olla niikuinii. Vaata, on ju mõtlengi. Vahet pole, see ei olegi tähtis.
Õpetaja: Ärge mõelge nagu seda üle, vaata, Mõelge lihtsalt sellele, mida te tegema peate. Alati võtate põhjas pasteri, mida te ei tea ja otsite enda tehtud asju panete õigesse kohta? See on See missioon, mida iganes. Jah, ma pean pusima ja vaeva nägema. Kui sa näiteks frontend ja ma pean nagu Atml I võtma ja nii edasi, siis sa teed. Seda
Õpetaja: Kui sa nagu back in. No siis sul tegelikult see väga keeruline kunagi ei ole ju? Otsi üles, Kurat, oma meetod.
Õpetaja: Oma mingisugust muutujat, Mis juurde lisasid? Pane nad õigesse kohta ja kooli või teen, kui ei ole midagi keerulist, siin, ei ole vaja midagi.
Õpetaja: Ja kui on alguses abi vaja, siis saad küsitagi abi. Lihtsalt nagu kedagi, et mul on see Merch konflikt, Ma ei tunne ennast väga kindlalt nagu. Vaata, et palun. Noh, kasvõi see, et ma proovin nüüd teha, aga vaata mind, kui ma teen seda, et Kas ma teen õigesti? Aga see ei ole nii keeruline. Te saate seda siin ka teha. Teate, tiimitööd.
Õpetaja: Teil on tiimitöö, kus teil on Vähe faile asju. Saar, et te hitite. Neid on väga suur. Saab ka töös niimoodi veits jaotada, et seda kokkupõrget on natukene nagu vähem, On ju Aga its. Gonna Happen
Õpetaja: Teil lõpuks on ikkagi niimoodi, et keegi teeb mingisuguse Ee, töö see läheb Masterisse. Teised peavad selle enda arvutisse kohe nagu tõmbama. Kas midagi hitid, et ta ütles samas failis?
Õpetaja: Noh, kui hitid. Noh, väga lihtne. Võtad selle teise venna töö põhjaks, Sa oled just siin natukene töötanud. Sa oled just siin mõned koodiread töötanud sa paremalt poolt. Teed selle lahti, vaatad enda koodiread ära, nagu Need on need, mis ma tegin.
Õpetaja: Noh, kõik käib niimoodi. Põmm ja olemas. Kõik unustad, lähme edasi.
Õpetaja: Et. Ee, aga sellest ei pääse
Õpetaja: Nii, Lähme edasi, Ee. Tahaks ikka praktilisi asju teha. Nüüd ka, mis me teeme nüüd selle arenduse raames. See nüüd on ära mörsitud. Nüüd Push In
Õpetaja: push in. Mina ära ka. Kui kui keegi tahab nagu täielikult tulla mulle nüüd igatepidi järgi, siis mis te saate teha, on see, et mina nüüd kustutan ju ka ära. Selle õpetaja Feb Seitsme Te kustutate ka, on ju?
Õpetaja: Kustutage kõik oma arendused harud ära.
Õpetaja: Kui ma Delin selle lokalist,
Õpetaja: siis ta peaks pakkuma mulle seda, et. Kas sa tahad ka Track Branch I ära kustutada?
Õpetaja: Ei kustutanud ei saa teha, Palun,
Õpetaja: mina. Mina kavatsen niimoodi, et minu, arvutisse jääb ainult. Noh, kaua ta nüüd push Ib. Mis ta nüüd kaua seda Push I teeb Viimasel ajal
Õpetaja: saarah,
Õpetaja: Sest et teil peaks ka oma haru peal olema. Noolekene, Te just mörsite mingisuguse asja enda arvutis ära, aga praegu läheb kool põlema. Arvuti põleb siia sisse. Noh, see tehtud töö ei ole ikkagi teil tegelikult seal kuskil pilves onju Push ige. See ära on ju
Õpetaja: nii minul ka ära. No mina kustutan ära. Kõik harud, välja arvatud enda nime. Ee ja Masteri ainu veb seitse,
Õpetaja: Ee, rein, feb seitse.
Õpetaja: Kui ta küsib kuskilt Eli, siis ma ütlen kustutuse ka,
Õpetaja: mis me tegelikult tahaksime, on see, et kui lõpuks nüüd Fetch I vajutada, Siis on siin alles ainult meie nimelised harud.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd siin on see koht, ka Kui keegi tahab. Nagu sõna otseses mõttes. Täpselt identselt tulla Mulle järgi. Te võite kustutada selle oma nimelise haaru ka ära
Õpetaja: ja võtta õpetaja pealt täiesti uus, puhas aru, et te võite kõik ära kustutada oma masterahaaru oma arenduse haru. Ja me hakkame täiesti nullist jälle pihta nagu Vaata nii, nagu nii,
Õpetaja: seda ei ole vaja teha, Vaata aga kui keegi lihtsalt tahab. Vaata, onju? Te võite tulla täiesti järgi.
Õpetaja: Jah, no ma mõtlen, ma mõtlen. No ta lõpuks pead, kellel tuli see konflikt. Vaata, kui ta tahtis mörsida,
Õpetaja: on ju? Noh, aa. Siis ongi. See. Vaata, mi. Miks on nagu seal on nagu see. Vaata, Cf. Vaata, kui Karin võttis tegelikult. Aa, minu haru kunagi. Vaata minu pealt mingi selle Kus ta tema enda master oli? See on Nagu nii nii vana. Vaata, et siin on vahepeal toimunud niivõrd palju muudatusi, et kui ta vahepeal tuli järgi minu arendusharudele,
Õpetaja: võttis kohe kuuse haaruse aruse ja ta lõpus tahtis möörsida seda tagasi oma
Õpetaja: sinna niiöelda enda masterharusse, onju? Siis sa lihtsalt tulid mingid konfliktid, et kui te Nüüd järgmises ringis tahate vältida, seda, siis ongi see, et kui algseis on nii nagu minul on
Õpetaja: nii nii, nagu minul on, on ju Ja lõpus see lõppseis on seal arendusalaga, Nii nagu minul on siis Merchantil Konflikte ei tule näiteks
Õpetaja: selgitada, kas ei ole üldse tähtis ka? Tehke staate praegult. Aa, peamine asi on see igal juhul, et me peame. Noh, vähemalt selle võite teha. Kui me nüüd võtame uue arenduse Haru, siis me võtame kõik selle õpetaja pealt.
Õpetaja: Kas kui nii. Kas te seda saate? Pärast Merchile tagasi enda arusse selgub? Vaata, teil peaks enamvähem joonel olema. Te lihtsalt mingi hetk võite teha seda, et te kustutate Lihtsalt ära oma. Nimelise haru ja võtate õpetajalt uuena no näitena Artur kustutaks enda haru ja võtaks õpetaja pealt uue haru ja paneks selle nimeks Artur,
Õpetaja: Siis on nagu täpselt joonel, kui tahaks, et kui Pärast tahame arendust tagasi mörtsida, siis ei tohiks tulla enam mingis konfliktist. Algseis on kõigil täpselt Sama
Õpetaja: mina. Samal ajal. Lähen vaatan nüüd, Ee, et sellega, panen to doust. Panen Dun I
Õpetaja: ja vaatame. Vaatame siis, mis on nagu järgmine. Aa, Task.
Õpetaja: Linnade on järgmine taas. No lähme Vaatame, mis toimub, Veb seitse. Vabandust, Sweb. Kümme.
Õpetaja: Selle Pildi võta. Mingi taustapilt on. Mul läinud kogu. Projektile on vist vä see. On mingi Header, kes
Õpetaja: see ei lähe kuidagi ära. See lihtsalt on
Õpetaja: mingi tabel. Aa, nii, vaatame ka korra. Siis Mis siin räägitakse? Räägitakse seda saab kuidagi eest ära panna. Andmebaasi mudel
Õpetaja: lisandub juurde üks Tabel City. Aga pange tähele, et temal ei ole ühtegi seost ühegi teise tabeliga, vähemalt Praegult mitte
Õpetaja: nii. Ja selles City tabelis.
Õpetaja: Ee, hakkab olema. Kurat, ma mõtlen, kas ma teeks natukene ühte asja teistmoodi
Õpetaja: ja
Õpetaja: teeme Teeme ühe asja teistmoodi kui tavaliselt. Aga teeme seda pausi ajal. Teeme pausi Praegult Ma teen väikse. Eeltöö
Õpetaja: paus vist.
Õpetaja: Ma panen rekordi ka ära ja Nüüd ma korra natukene
Õpetaja: tekitage oma uus master. Eelkõige sellepärast, et siin on ühed Script I failid sees. Ma ei viitsi neid slaki koogi toppida. Ee, et kustutage Minge korra Masteri peale. Päris Masteri peale. Kustutage oma haru ära
Õpetaja: ja võtke õpetaja pealt uus haaru, sellepärast et ma Panin mingisugust staffi, ja kuidas?
Õpetaja: Ja nii on kõige lihtsam Lihtsalt praegu, et on teine Workeround. Ka, aga lihtsalt. Lihtsam on niimoodi praegult,
Õpetaja: aga Fetch. Enne seda, kui võtate. Muidu ei ole teil. Mäletate, et kui te võtate haru, siis ta võtab? Tegelikult tee sealt sellest Ee, arvutist On ju sellest peegel? Peegelduse pealt, mäletate? Teil on peegeldus siin tegelikult
Õpetaja: remonti all,
Õpetaja: et, ee, seal ei ole kohe, muidu võibolla sees nii Kui ära siis on. Ja eesmärk on siis see, et me võtame andmebaasi selles mõttes kasutusele, et meil on ka millestki nagu natuke rohkem rääkida.
Õpetaja: Räägin asju, mis ma tavaliselt natukene hiljem räägin.
Õpetaja: Ee, mulle tundub tegelikult. See on mõistlikum ee eesmärk. On siis selline et, tekib juurde siia juurkataloogi nimelt saate alati kõike lahti teha ja saate teise nupu kõike kinni panna colaps all,
Õpetaja: et siin juurkataloogis on nüüd olemas üks Uus kataloog. Mingi database.
Õpetaja: Seda te peaksite siis nägema. See on, mida me soovime.
Õpetaja: Käsi püsti. Kas kedagi veel? Ootan Viimari, et mida me Tahame seda seda kataloogi soovime näha.
Õpetaja: On olemas, Okei? Kas keegi veel peab ootama? Käsi püsti korra ootan.
Õpetaja: Jah, aga sul seda ei ole veel vaja. Praegu
Õpetaja: ei ole. Praegu sa pead tegema lihtsalt Aa, Riho Nimelise haru õpetaja pealt.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd järgmine asi, mis me soovime teha, on siis see, et me siin on andmebaasi?
Õpetaja: Esimene asi, mis ta teeb, on see et vaatab, et kas andmebaasis on. Ütleme siis hästi Niimoodi laialt. Ee, jämedalt võttes, et kas on olemas andmebaasis Niukene kaust nagu pank. See tegelikult ei ole kaust, vaid seda kutsutakse tehniliseks Skeemaks.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on nagu mingi mudel. Nagu või mida iganes, kuidas sellest mõelda. Aga teie saate mõelda sellest, kui kaustast,
Õpetaja: et siin, nagu, et Kas on olemas kaustamiga pank?
Õpetaja: Kui Jah, siis kustuta see ära. Ja järgmises sammus. Öeldakse juba, et loo uus keema pank ja anna talle Mingid vajalikud õigused, et seda sellele võimalik ligi saada.
Õpetaja: Siis on järgmine. Script on see on nüüd esku eelkõik.
Õpetaja: See Script põhimõtteliselt ütleb loo Tabel City loo Tabel Location Loo Tabel profile. Loo Tabel Location image ja tead
Õpetaja: ühtlasi luuakse
Õpetaja: seosed tabelite vahel erinevate erinevate tabelitega, No mis Kõik See on. Sellest. Räägin hiljem nüüd. Viimane script on import Script.
Õpetaja: Siin on siis, et sisestab ee, tabelisse role Väärtused Admin ja customer
Õpetaja: Ee, siselda tabelisse user. Ee, admin üks, kaks, kolm, Status A rain, üks, kaks, kolm, A, Mitte aktiivne. Bla blabla. Need script Id, siis Lisavad andmeid. Me Sql Ile väga palju ei peatu. Praegu.
Õpetaja: Mida see asi nagu tervikuna teeb, on see, et ta kustutab ära olemasoleva jama Kaustas Pank
Õpetaja: loob selle uuesti selle kaustapank ja loob sinna tabelid ja paneb sinna andmeid.
Õpetaja: Mina kutsun seda tegevust nagu kokku. Põhimõtteliselt.
Õpetaja: Ehk Meil on mingi mingisugused tabelid. Meil on mingisugused algandmed seal, et oleks millegagi võimalik kohe toimetada ja vaadata Aa ja laseb mingi vana asja õhku, Kui me sinna hakkame juurde mingit pläusti lisama. Nii
Õpetaja: Nüüd, et andmebaasiga suhelda, on teile kõigil peaks olema. Niukene asi. Ärge seda avage, aga Kui Te otsite Pg Admin
Õpetaja: tuleb elevant.
Õpetaja: See nüüd on, ee. Siis põhimõtteliselt andmebaasi andmebaasi. Brauser või lehitseja,
Õpetaja: kes Siis on võimeline nagu vaatama mingit andmebaasi sisu Kui teil on oma arvutisse installeeritud andmebaas, siis see on üks asi, et seal taustal on olemas tehniliselt andmebaas,
Õpetaja: millel on võimalik saata siis läbi programmide käske, et lisa siia uus tabelisse rida. Või mis iganes, kujutage niimoodi ette. Aga teine asi on see, kuidas Te saate vaadata seda andmebaasi Teil on vaja mingit lehitsejat.
Õpetaja: Kui te installisite peale, siis vaikimisse, tuleb kaasa valida, aga ta on vaikimisse sees, See on lihtsalt ehitsaja
Õpetaja: On olemas teise mingisugused Ee, programmid nagu
Õpetaja: ee, mõned muud veel. Ee, mis mulle meeldib. Ja nii edasi. Ja Nii Edasi ehk siis programmid, mis on teevad täpselt seda sama asja, et on võimalik andmebaasi vaadata. Tee Mõelge justkui Brauserist Browseriga on võimalik vaadata. Veebilehte, onju?
Õpetaja: Tegelt taustal on mingisugune kood ja asjad. Vaata seda te ju ei vaata, on ju? Te võtate mingi asjast tõlgendates seda asja
Õpetaja: Nüüd vist on tore. Asi on see, et seda me ei pea kasutama. Ma võin selle käivitada, aga siis ta hakkab siin käivitama seda Sada tundi installimise käigus. Sa tegelikult pidi seda tegema korra,
Õpetaja: et on seal olemas. Mis meil on, on see, et meil on
Õpetaja: integreeritud arenduskeskkond Meie Powerfull Wonderful Super Word on drugs.
Õpetaja: Ee on steroids. Siia on sisse integreeritud Ultimate iga aga andmebaasi Connection database tool
Õpetaja: ehk siis mugav Koht, kus me saame kohe vaadata andmebaasi tabelite andmeid. Selles samas tööriistas
Õpetaja: Niukene Julla peaks teil siin olema.
Õpetaja: Selline Tööriist
Õpetaja: Selle tööriista me Kõik Teeme lahti Ja mis me nüüd teeme? Kui teil on kõik need õigesti sätestatud, siis saate seda vaadata. Kui teil on midagi installimata ja midagi veel vaja teha. Vaadata, Siis tegeleme sellega.
Õpetaja: Classrooms. Lihtsalt vaatate. Aga Me saame nüüd öelda, et meil, on siia sisse installitud meie masinasse kohalik andmebaas. Aga me tahame öelda, et me sooviks vaadata sealt ühte konkreetset
Õpetaja: Ee tabelit, tabelit? Vabandust,
Õpetaja: andmebaasi. Plussi juurest tulete et soovin luua Connection it data source, et kuule, mis and Mis andmusbaasis sa räägid siit. Me soovime üles otsida niukse asja nagu
Õpetaja: vaikimised on tavaliselt selle peal on mingi Cloud versioonid. Aa, Amazoni. Mingi variant. Mida iganes meil see tavaline asi sobib. Klikime sealt selle peale
Õpetaja: tuleb lahti üks aken Seda võib natuke laiemaks venitada, et paremini näeb.
Õpetaja: Nüüd me peame siin mõningad asjad ära täitma.
Õpetaja: Esiteks on see, et kes, on user,
Õpetaja: user on postgress, kui te installisite ja tegite asju täpselt nii nagu vaja. See on postkres siit ülevalt, kus on praegu vaikimisi genereeritud mingi nimi Siit te saate copida juba selle sõna Postgress
Õpetaja: kontol C ja panna siia Control V või kirjutada lihtsalt, ee, trükkides. Vahet pole, Password,
Õpetaja: Kui Te nüüd tegite vastavalt juhenditele ja panite selle Password I, mis oli seal nõutud, siis see on student.
Õpetaja: Üks, kaks, kolm, mul pärast tuksi.
Õpetaja: Student aega. Üks, kaks, kolm,
Õpetaja: Ahaa Teil on täiesti uus asi. Kas teil siin all on mingi nupp, Download Drivers või midagi taolist kuskil
Õpetaja: Jah, seda kui sa. Minul on juba draiver olemas. Ma ei saa seda näidata.
Õpetaja: On teil siin Download? Klikkige seda.
Õpetaja: See on, lihtsalt ee, Põhimõtteliselt juhendid Aa sellele intellige tööriistale, et kuidas ta saab täpselt suhelda andmebaasiga?
Õpetaja: See käib mingi väga, kiire et see download, see on mingi Pisikene sutsakas.
Õpetaja: Nii, kui teil on tehtud ära see, et teil on siin see poskress. Teil on student. Üks, kaks, kolm ja kui te Nüüd vajutate nuppu. Test Connection.
Õpetaja: Siis peaks tulema ette.
Õpetaja: No kohe, kui tuleb selline asi.
Õpetaja: Kui kellelgi ei tule, siis meid praegult see ei huvita. Me tegeleme väljapool seda loengut. Sellega ülisavi Me niikuinii vaatame asju.
Õpetaja: Kellegile tuli mingi error. No võite korra veel proovida, siis parooli uuesti panna.
Õpetaja: Kui siis ka ei tööta. No siis on midagi halvasti ja siis tegeleb sellega väljapool seda tundi.
Õpetaja: Kui kõik on olemas, siis ta näitab seda, et ta juba suutis Connect Ida ära teie kohaliku.
Õpetaja: Ee. Selle nüüd te võite vajutada, Apply, aga enne seda võiks panna mingi Normaalse nime. Selle ta genereeris, lihtsalt, et see on kohaliku masina. Sinu arvutis olev andmebaas postkress. Nüüd saage aru, see asi on teie arvutis,
Õpetaja: See on teie arvutis. Kui te hakkate tegelema tiimitööd ja projektides andmed, ei ole teil läbi selles mõttes kuidagi seotud. See andmebaas on teie arvates, kui sina ikka lisad Tabelisse mingi muu rea juurde, siis see on sinu arvutis mitte su naabri. Minginaabri arvutus.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, meie paneks Mingi lihtsama nime Paneme siit database
Õpetaja: ta. Lihtsalt. Kuidas me siit üleval hakkame nägema mingit ee, asju ja siis paneb lihtsalt nimeks ja siis Okei,
Õpetaja: nüüd tema päriselt siin ülevalt üritab siis selle Aa Connectioniga ühendust luua. Ta veetsin renderdab mida iganes
Õpetaja: Me saame teha. Nupukese, niimoodi ma ei tea, kuidas neid noolnupukesi Kutsuda. Noolekese. Peame lahti teha.
Õpetaja: Ja see on siis see meie niiöelda postkast tabel, kus me näeme erinevaid skeemasid Nüüd vaikimisi tuleb kaasa. Public. Vot see on nüüd Skeema
Õpetaja: ja see script siin, mis siin ütleb? Aa, mis iganes meil on plaanis luua juurde. Üks eraldi Skeema vaikimisi on kaasas public. Kõik info läheb sinna. Aga me tahame niimoodi, et ee, meil konkreetselt selle projekti jaoks on Nagu oma tabelid ja asjad.
Õpetaja: No näed, mul on see mingid. Tabelid ja asjad. Ee, hetkel on ma näen. Need On selle minu, see Projekt See
Õpetaja: Ee klassiraha. Asjad on siin mida iganes,
Õpetaja: aga meie tahame teha ühte niukest kausta põhimõtteliselt juurde
Õpetaja: ja et seda saada, siis me Läheme, teeme database I lahti Selle kataloogi. Haome selle esimese Scripti.
Õpetaja: Näete, see esimene Scription siis, kui juba on olemas pank, siis kustuta ära, Aga järgnevad read loovad selle
Õpetaja: nüüd. Kas teil on see plainupukene või Ei ole?
Õpetaja: Kõigil on kellegil. Ei olegi siin niipidi
Õpetaja: kui nüüd seda käivitada, siis ta tegelikult tahab võtta seda osa, kus peal sa hiirega oled? Et siin on mõistlik kontrol a Jaoks teha et, kõik on selektitud, et jooksul näete. See on üks statement. See on üks ee. Mis asi on Sql?
Õpetaja: Sql on query Language Struktueeritud päringu keel
Õpetaja: see on Siis keel, mis süntaks, mille abil on võimalik suhelda andmebaatega keel. Nagu iga teine keel, on see, et sea ritta sõnad õiges järjekorras
Õpetaja: Õige sisuga, siis. Tal on mingi miining tähtsus. See keel on juba tegelikult üsna okeilt ja lähedane. Arusaadav ka päris inglise keelele, Aa, mõned Sõnad lihtsalt alguses. Näiteks. Ee. Vajavad nagu, Aa, võibolla harjumist, aga. No kui me vaatame näiteks Tabeli loom loomist, vaatame
Õpetaja: Table Tabeli nimi, veerud, Mis seal on seal sees? Id, tüüp,
Õpetaja: vaikimisi, sätted. Kas on kohustuslik või mitte? Tegelikult, see on suht lihtne. Siin on pank. Anna Kõik, Õigused, bla, blabla. Mida iganes
Õpetaja: vahet pole, praegu, ignoreeri.
Õpetaja: Mul ei ole mitte midagi sees. Ma ei ole midagi,
Õpetaja: Mul ei ole mitte midagi Sellist Kümme veel
Õpetaja: kas. Sa ennem said selle rohelise märgi
Õpetaja: siis? Siis Tegeleme sellega hiljem whatever. Me, Ei me, ei peatu Me Lähme edasi vähemalt selle
Õpetaja: admin leida. Programmi avama
Õpetaja: ei pea, ei pea, lähme edasi. Kellel on praegu mingid tehnilised probleemid ja asjad absoluutselt ükstaspuha Vaadake lihtsalt minu ekraani.
Õpetaja: Nii, Aa, aga need, kes saavad kaasa teha, siis teevad seda. Vaata, teised lihtsalt vaatavad Osana See ei ole Praegu Me peame edasi liikuma. Mis me nüüd teeme, on see, et niipea, kui seda seda jooksutada, kõik on sinine,
Õpetaja: jooksutame nüüd. Ta küsib Connection It seda Sama Connection It. Kui ta küsib, et kui tahad mingit Scripti siin jooksutada, siis võid alati, öelda, et kasuta vaikimise skeemat, eriti selle skripti puhul ülisavi database. Just default skeema
Õpetaja: Nüüd taustal, mis toimub, lähevad päriselt. Aa, päringud andmebaasi vastu. Näete, ma teen niukse Service niukse näitab, et Mis andmebaasil läksid? Käsud blogib. Ja mida iganes,
Õpetaja: Mis nüüd järgmisena on? Ee, meil teada või mis on põnev on see, et nüüd peaks Tekkima juurde siia. Üks uus kataloog.
Õpetaja: Pank.
Õpetaja: Nii tuli.
Õpetaja: Väga tore, sest et mis me nüüd tahame teha, on see.
Õpetaja: Me tahame jooksutada, kui ta nüüd kuskilt Siit küsib, et, ee, sul ei ole pandud paika, et, ee. Mis on dialekt? Siis dialekt on Vahepe Kui tuleb. Ettevõtlus Tuleb võib kõik kinni panna. Mis nüüd on olemas, on see, et me saame tulla siia database alla ja valida et Kuule,
Õpetaja: niimoodi valime. Siit
Õpetaja: tuleb, Valime kõik need kolm faili Ja järjekord on tähtis. Kui te nii nii siis tuleb vale tulemus. Me tahame tegelikult, et on Kõigepealt klikid esimesele ja siis hoiad Shift I. Hoiad viimasele või kontrolliga, aga vähemalt õiges järjekorras
Õpetaja: ja teeme parema klõpsu ja tahame öelda, et Ole hea, jooksuta neid scripte. Parem klõps ja run
Õpetaja: eraldi lahti. Ühe niukse tabeli. Mitte tabeli. Vabandust, vaata
Õpetaja: samamoodi, nagu me database ile panime, Lihtsalt nime näete. See siin database saab selle skripti jooksutamisele panna. Mingi nime vaikimisse. Tema pani, et reset peegeldab, seda et jooksutad. Kolme Scripti, Me tahaks panna siia lihtsalt reset
Õpetaja: database. Sa võid siia kirjutada nimeks mida iganes. Sul Lihtsalt pärast mugav. Seda siin üleval selles siin selles kohas näha, kus me saame asju jooksutada. See tekib siia ka nüüd. Tema näitab, et. Ee. Mina soovin jooksutada neid Scripte sellises järjekorras Nad peavad olema sellises järjekorras. Kui nad on mingi muu järjekorras,
Õpetaja: siis siin on väike sõltuvus ja see asi ei toimi, et igal juhul siin Tuleb paika panna. Nüüd. Kõige tähtsam on see, et tema ei tea, mis Connection I vastu. Mul võib olla viis viis erinevat database siin Arvutis või või online, Mis iganes, kuhu. Kuhu need skriptid hakkavad käivituma. Et mis andmebaasi vastu nad läheb?
Õpetaja: Siis Meie soovime, öelda et plussi alt, et. Kuule, me tahame kasutada seda database. Teeme linnukese lahti. Postgress ja täpse. Kõige täpsemalt selle kataloogi või skeema vastu Pank topeltklõps
Õpetaja: Kui Te nüüd näete database pank. Nüüd need Script Id lähevad konkreetselt selle
Õpetaja: kataloogi vastu. Ma ütlen kataloog, aga see on skeema. Teil on lihtsalt mõelda, nagu see on nagu kaust. Seal ei ole Meie panga asjad oma projektis on midagi muud kui pank, onju?
Õpetaja: Nii?
Õpetaja: Nüüd on see asi, et edaspidi saab lihtsalt käivitada reset database. Tema käivitab need kolm Scripti selle tabeli või? Vabandust selle andmebaasi vastu
Õpetaja: võib panna Apply, et Tal jääb see meelde. Aga põhiline on nüüd hoopis see rand.
Õpetaja: Jällegi, Kui ei saa praegu kaasa teha või midagi, siis lihtsalt vaatad Nii
Õpetaja: Kui nüüd vaid tata minul Felis.
Õpetaja: Aga ma arvan, et ta on mingit jama. Ma ei usu. Ee, kui ma nüüd tulen siia panga juurde Vajutan klikin selle. Peale. Vajutan korra, Refresh.
Õpetaja: Siis mul peaks tulema siia alla tables.
Õpetaja: Andsequences on? Nii Ma tuletan meelde ühte Excelit, mis Me varem ka vaatasime.
Õpetaja: Mäletate, kui me korra nagu vaatasime, et kuidas? Nagu Id D tekivad Tabelisse? Me Korra rääkisime. Mäletate seda, et kui tulevad siia, Read siis tema võtab Sequent Counter Ist Ee, nagu järgmise. Ee, rea paneb. Kõigepealt pluss üks ja nüüd saab seda siin Kasutada. Mäletate
Õpetaja: Seconds Counter? Näete seda siin
Õpetaja: andmebaasis? On meil niimoodi, et kõik asjad, mis on Primeri keed. Nende jaoks luuakse Sequence Counter, Kui mul on Tabel City,
Õpetaja: Siis mul on ka City It Seconds. Counter. See sama elukas põhimõtteliselt lahti pildidatakse. Võtad võetud Kui mina. Nüüd ee, tulen siia mõne tabeli peale Vaatan. Näiteks City.
Õpetaja: Teen Niimoodi klõps. Klõps?
Õpetaja: Noh, võibolla hetkel võtab aega siis tema teeb City Tabeli lahti.
Õpetaja: Siin on näha. Vaata, veerud Id ja name Näete. Seda kollast võtit.
Õpetaja: See on Primeri Key. See tähendab seda, et see on unikaalne väärtus selles tabelis, Mis on kordumatult unikaalne. Forever and Ever. Iga võti lihtsalt on siis konkreetse reaks. See ei ole lihtsalt järjend. Loed Näete, siin Intelligencia näitab, ka, et mis reaal sa oled?
Õpetaja: No ma panen järjestuse. Näiteks teistpidi. Ma panen need. Ee, panen niimoodi Pärnu. Tallinn Tartu selle poodi.
Õpetaja: Kuidas Miks ta. Peaks seda tegema?
Õpetaja: Ei muidugi mitte.
Õpetaja: Mõtlesin. Mugav oleks.
Õpetaja: Noh, see ei oleks mitte kunagi. Mida sa sooviks ju, et mina tahan, et mul on script mingist asjast, kus on minu andmed. Ja nagu mingi keegi. Ja siis oleks väga keeruline küsimus kui sina, Kui me. Näiteks? Mul on sellel andmebaasil ligipääs sinul teisel. Vaata, et ei, see ei ole. Nad ei ole kuidagi süngis ja see on asi, Mida on vaja meeles hoida.
Õpetaja: Pigem on vist seal vaja meeles hoida see, et, ee,
Õpetaja: kuidas see nagu asi nagu töötab, on ju Töötabki niimoodi, Et iga kord, kui tuleb üks uus kanne
Õpetaja: Aa, taustal, Mis toimetab. On? See on siin Brauser. Ma teen korra Refresh I ja lasen seal minna.
Õpetaja: Ma teen korra siit. Ee,
Õpetaja: ma ei tea, kas ma saan siit näha neid või mitte. Ma vaatan korra, kui ma siin midagi teen. Ee, ma panen Refresh.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin Ma ei näe, aga ma teen käsitsi seda ja nii. Või naa. Meil on Niukene asi ka siin juures. Nagu päringu konsol.
Õpetaja: See vaatamise koht. Kui mina teen selle lahti. Ma võtan jälle Default. Consol
Õpetaja: sind hoiab meeles, kui ma midagi. Kirjutan ja panen kinni. Vahet pole, kui ma teen uuesti koeri konsoli lahti ja ütlen, et on see vaikimise konsool,
Õpetaja: ta on nagu Jagatud Space. Ta teeb niukse Väikse Working Space. Ma ei tea, kas siin näitab kaal. Näed, väike konsol. Siin Scratches and Consols. Ta hoiab Lihtsalt meeles,
Õpetaja: kui mina kirjutaksin. Kuidas sellel tabeli Tema sai? Põhimõtteliselt taustal. Ma ei peaks saama näha ka, kus seda logi saab vaadata
Õpetaja: meenutama Hästi, natukene service alla. Äkki konsool? Vaatame korra see City tabel Vot Nii Kui ma. Teen Refresh
Õpetaja: siis praegult, mida intellige tegi Select From Banks City. Anna mulle read kuni viissada üks tähemärki. Order by Name
Õpetaja: Seda tegi meie eest, et kuidas need andmed siia tekivad? Intellige ise ei ole kuidagi arendanud Endal nagu seda, et Kuidas ta. Saab andmebaasil ligi? Ta lihtsalt saadab päringuid. Seda sama päringut saame meie ise ka teha. See on vaatamise koht. Kui mina teen Select, võtan selle templi,
Õpetaja: siis praegu. Ta ütleb, et võta kõik veerud
Õpetaja: tabelist ja nüüd ootab Ja nüüd ma tahan talle öelda. Bank punkt City.
Õpetaja: Ja ma panen selle alla. Kui ma nüüd käivitan. Selle ko selle selle lause
Õpetaja: tuleb alla. Täpselt samasugune tabel, nagu oli põhimõtteliselt siin. No ma panen Id järgi ka. Saate aru mõttes
Õpetaja: suhtleb andmebaasiga. Sql lausel
Õpetaja: struktureeritud päringu keel Siin on oma kindel struktuur. Pane ainult sõnu õiges reas ritta ja tema teeb täpselt seda, mida sina tahad, Annab andmeid, kirjutab andmeid ja Nii edasi. Selles mõttes rohkem nagu ei vaata. Mina lihtsalt tahan, et te saaksite nüüd aru.
Õpetaja: Need ongi need andmed konkreetselt, mis moodustavad meie
Õpetaja: me. Kui me ei pea. Kui tuleb näiteks juurde viljandi, siis keegi lihtsalt. Vaat Süsteemide In läheb viljandi.
Õpetaja: Aitab, Enter. Ma teen korra jälle selle konsooli lahti.
Õpetaja: Vaata, mis juhtub, kui ma. See See, et ma hoidsin entrit, ei juhtu mitte midagi
Õpetaja: ennem, kui ma ei vajuta seda noolekest submit,
Õpetaja: siis ta veel ei tee. Mul on võimalus siin midagi taganeda. See, see on brau. See on lihtsalt nagu visuaalne brauser, kui Ma toon siia konsoli juurde tagasi. Ee, kuidas ma seda sain? Ennem vaadata? Service alt, onju?
Õpetaja: Siia konsooli alla tulen. Panen siit kinni, logi Output logi Ma panen Clear, et on lihtsam näha.
Õpetaja: Ai, vabandust, Ma tahtsin selle alla tulla. Claire, Mina kavatsen siit selle tööriista alt lihtsalt Lisada ühe rea juurde. Vaadake, mis taustal juhtub. Mina vajutan Submit
Õpetaja: Blax Lause insert. Into pank. See on see kaust, sa täpsemalt.
Õpetaja: Vaata punktiga Läheb natuke nagu onju? Punktiga läheb sügavamale.
Õpetaja: Seal on veerud Id ja name. Mina tahan panna sinna väärtused Default ja viljandi Default on see
Õpetaja: Ta saab aru, et see on Niukene väli, mis suudab automaatselt ise
Õpetaja: enda seda ee väärtust saada. See tuleb sellest Hickens Counter ist. Näed, Siit tuleb see. Tema hoiab meeles. Seda vist kuidagi vaadata ei saa. Vaata, onju nagu väärtust, mis sel hetkel on? Aga Seal on Niukene Counter.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui ma kustutan selle ära. Näed, siin oli Insert Into. No ma. Nüüd jälle teen all, et on lihtsalt näha, kui ma siin tööriistas. Kustutan selle ära. Vajutan miinus siin ja vajutan Submit
Õpetaja: kolm. Ta ütles, et kustuta ära rida kus oli, Id kolm kadus ära,
Õpetaja: Kui ma panen nüüd uuesti siia tagasi Ja ma panen, mis oli. Pärnu vist oli, mis ma kutsusin ära, on ju? Ma panen pärnu Uuesti
Õpetaja: pärnu. Sellist kohta pole. Võibolla on ka. Ma ei tea, vaid Renterit.
Õpetaja: Ma teen siit jälle puhtaks platsi, et on lihtsalt hea näha Seda logist
Õpetaja: tuleb insert. Lause default väärtus võetakse ise. Järgmine on viis
Õpetaja: unikaalselt. See Läheb kogu aeg ülesse ülesse ülesse ülesse.
Õpetaja: Kui näete nüüd. Me käivitasime seda. Mul on see frontend server. Kui mõnus on see, et kui ma käivitan serverit, siis ma teen seda niimoodi, kui ma Tahan, et ee. Kustuta kogu see asi ära. Loo uuesti need tabelid ja lisa sisu. Näete siis kogu see pläust, mis siin on?
Õpetaja: Tulen Panen reset database. Vajutan play nuppu.
Õpetaja: Tuleb veel ette, et kas soovid seda jooksutada? Noh, see sama aken, mis ennem oli Run kustutab kõik Ära
Õpetaja: teeb uuesti, kui ma nüüd teen. Siin City tabelis. Refresh on algseis.
Õpetaja: See on selleks, et me saame arenduse käigus. Ee, midagi asja testida. Me oleme laisad, vennad. Kui on vaja panna nimi eestlane, perekonna nimi. Viitsi enam testides kirjutada. Igale poole näitad, et Rain ja tüüp Ja Mida iganes? Ma panen sisse andmebaasis mingi noh, koledad. Mingid andmed on ju?
Õpetaja: Ja see database Back To Square One, Vaata, et kõik Tabelites on need andmed mis on vaja.
Õpetaja: Kas tahaks neid? Ee, Id s ka, et nad oleks ilusti nagu vahenumbrid oleks nagu Noh, järjest. Tuleks.
Õpetaja: Miks sa. Miks sul seda vaja on? Ma küsin,
Õpetaja: me. Me. Ei. Sa. Sa näed seda ja sa saad neid andmeid kasutada, Aga Minu Küsimus on Ocd, vä?
Õpetaja: Mhm, eks? Sa saad kõik. Kas saab seda? Teha Sa saad mingi Scripti kirjutada. Mis automaatne script, mis käib Kõik su miljonid kiired andmebaasid läbi ja panevad uuesti ritta, nagu onju.
Õpetaja: Miks sul seda vaja jääb? Jääb selgusetuks. Vaata, et sa ei vaata neid neid Id S. E enam kunagi Tegelikult
Õpetaja: kujutage ette et teil on süsteem, kus on mingid panga maksed. Näiteks mingi
Õpetaja: ühes kuus on Mingi miljon makset
Õpetaja: ei ole vaja. Pigem ongi see. Vaata, kui sina tahaksid neid ritta panna. Vaata aga, sa ei saa ka. See on Hästi, keeruline. Vaadake, ee. Võtame nüüd siis mingisuguse näite siin. Ee, võtame näite Näiteks Väga hea user.
Õpetaja: Idest ei jää puudu ja me mingi Ulmenumbritest. Räägime juba. Jah, ma unusta ära, Aga vaata, mis pro. Mis on Nagu probleemsemad kohad.
Õpetaja: Vaata, meil on siin kaks tabelit, meil on Siin user ja ma teen ühe tabeli veel siia. Kõrvale lahti. Ee, teen lahti. Role.
Õpetaja: Tõstan selle rooli siia niimoodi alla, et me näeme Mõlemad korraga
Õpetaja: siin. Role. Tabeli user tabelis. Meil on mingisugused andmed. Aga Nüüd on viited. Rollitabeli Id le. Näete, see Primer I Gee on Kollane võti.
Õpetaja: Aga võti, mis vii, viitab kellegi teise Tabeli Primer I keele. Siis siin tabelis on ta sinine võti. Foreign ki.
Õpetaja: Need asjad tulevad automaatselt. Need on enda täidetavad. Kas programmiliselt või mitte, Vahet pole enda täidetavad. Kui me lisame admini, me viitame. Me võtame näiteks mitteaktiivne
Õpetaja: Mitte aktiivne on username. Password on üks, kaks, kolm. Status on D. Nagu Vahet pole.
Õpetaja: Mis tema roll on? No Tema roll on role Id kaks. Vaata, tema roll on see.
Õpetaja: Kujutame ette, et ma toon siia ühe rolli juurde Mingi panen moderaator.
Õpetaja: Teeme juurde nii okei, kui Ma tahaks ära kustutada praegult seda siit vahelt
Õpetaja: Ja submitida. Siis ta ütleb ä,
Õpetaja: mis ta ütleb, mis Talle ei meeldi,
Õpetaja: et ee, updator Delete Role, et siin update või delete, on probleem, sest et siin see qi Kaks
Õpetaja: mida, mis, on siin olemas on, viidatud kuskil teises tabelis.
Õpetaja: Kui seda rida pole enam,
Õpetaja: Kujutame ette, et. Noh, pange näpp ette sinna, või mis iganes. Vaata, et seda. Pole. Enam,
Õpetaja: siis on Küsimus see, et millele kuradile need kaks rida siis viitavad
Õpetaja: Id le mida enam, ei ole olemas.
Õpetaja: Et See, mõte on see, et kui Sa peaksid hakkama neid numbreid siin nüüd uuesti järjestama. Siis need numbrid on kuskil teises tabelis juba viidatud.
Õpetaja: Sa peaksid need ka korda tegema.
Õpetaja: Noh, Ja, see asi võib kaskadeeruvalt minna. Nagu, väga, väga jälgiks.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis Ossi tee on see koht, kus sa seekord annad alla nagu, Et jah, sul sulle jääb see rahu. Sul jääb see meele, et nad vähemalt on kasvavalt. Nagu selles mõttes, et nad alati on kasvavad,
Õpetaja: Nii okei,
Õpetaja: väga tore. Ma olen ka see vend. Vaata, ma tahaks ka neid korda teha mulle meeldib siis andmed sisestada niimoodi, et nad Vähemalt võimalikult Täpselt alguses läheks. Ma lõpus läheb niikuinii virvariks ära, nii et vahet pole
Õpetaja: nüüd, kõige tähtsam on aru saada seda, et andmed tulevad tabelist.
Õpetaja: See on praegult. Mille jaoks me selle vaeva ette võtsime? Me võtsime vaeva, ette et me edaspidi saame ka neid tabeleid ja andmeid vaadata.
Õpetaja: Just tekitasid sinna siis, kui öelda. Kas kuskil on mingi Exceli tabel Mille sa midagi ei konmenteeri siis
Õpetaja: peab ise kreitima, ei Pea ise kreitima. This Dna.
Õpetaja: No mis te arvate, kes saaks teha neid andmeid? Need on käsitsi tekitatud. Ei, ei, vaata mul. Ma nüüd Näitan, kuidas ma tegelikult tekitasin. Tegelikult Tekitasin ikkagi tabelid. Ma tekitasin ee läbi. Sinna jõuame üks hetk.
Õpetaja: Ma tegin need andmed esimesel korral ise Nii, Ja nüüd ma näitan seda teile ka. Mingi hetk. Siis Mingi hetk. Ma tegin niimoodi et ma tulen. Võtan näiteks Citytabeli andmed,
Õpetaja: no Ma ei pea selectima ega midagi. Ma lihtsalt tulen siia. Näete siit nuppe? Eksport ja copy to database ja mingid nupud, Eksport, Mis see Tähendab, eksport. Data,
Õpetaja: ma saan. Ma saan nagu praegult eksportida neid andmeid.
Õpetaja: Mina praegu tulen siia juurde. Vaata See eksport. Data Preview. Ta näitab, et ekstraktor on Csv. Mis on Csv?
Õpetaja: See oli,
Õpetaja: Mis tähendab Csv? See on Ad. See on agronüümia. Tähendab midagi ja komaga eraldatud väärtused. See on representatsioon nendest andmetest komadega. Hetkel siin. Headerit ei ole Id ja name. Kui sa ütled, et. Oo, ma tahan eksportida. Näed, teda, mõtled. Tahad faili teha? Isegi lausa. Kui tahad, paned,
Õpetaja: saate aru, mis see vahe on,
Õpetaja: nii? Aga kui Minul on mingid andmed juba olemas, Siis, ee, kes ütleb, et ma tahan neid Csv. Nagu üldse nagu ma tahaks nüüd hoopis lauset. Täna palun väga.
Õpetaja: Siin Midagi ei muuda kunagi. Ükskord muutusid Natukene. Kahju, et enam ei tee.
Õpetaja: Okei? Et saate aru niimoodi. Copy to clipboard või export to file ja,
Õpetaja: noh, lähed oma te edaspidi hakata. Oma töödes ka nii tegema. Lähed importi, lisasite mingisugused andmed
Õpetaja: panete pläraki maha ja. No natuke peate sinna üht teist tegema. Ma räägin hiljem sellest.
Õpetaja: Kas sa ei vastab teie küsimusele, Kus ma need andmed sain?
Õpetaja: Aga saab ka andmeid väga edukalt, et annad Selle annad Chatile selle skeema ette.
Õpetaja: Vaata nagu, palun. Mul on niuksed tabelid.
Õpetaja: Tee mulle palun Mingid Inser Id nagu, noh, kui ta teab ärimudelit ka, et. Noh, mis siin toimub? Ja nii edasi ta oskab genereerida mingi Meaningfull staff i
Õpetaja: selle Csv faili kuskilt importida, ühendada, importida, Minu meelest ei saa,
Õpetaja: ma ei ole kindel. Noh, Chat I küsimus. Kõik on võimalik teha suure tõenäosusega. Jah, võimalik ka ma ise ei ole seda kasutanud. Mulle, meeldi Mul on vaja nüüd lauset.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: ee, see selleks. Nüüd tuleme jälle selle punkti juurde. Ärme rohkem küsimusi. Me Tuleme veel nende juurde tagasi, kui me tuleme Backendi või? Ma lihtsalt tahan praegult, et te saaksite aru, et need andmed, mis nüüd järgnevast tulevad, tulevad sellest tabelist.
Õpetaja: Nüüd lõpuks saame siia Feb Seitsme juurde minna.
Õpetaja: See Vaata, et lisandub mängu Niuke tabel,
Õpetaja: user ja Role on juba Varasemast meil eelmisest task ist Kui sisse logid,
Õpetaja: kui sisse logid. Kui. No vaatame korra veel ülevaate nüüd. On hea võimalus
Õpetaja: kui sina logid sisse. Admin üks, kaks, kolm, siis Sinu user. Id on üks, on nii?
Õpetaja: Ja sinu rol on mitte üks, vaid lähme vaatame rol tabelist, Mis üks on?
Õpetaja: Number üks on admin role. Name Rol Name on admin.
Õpetaja: Ja sinu user. Id user. Id on üks. Saate aru, Need Ongi need andmed
Õpetaja: selle vastu. Me hakkamegi pärast sisselogimist tegema. Vaatame seda väärtust. Vaatame seda väärtust. Mis siit see tuleb? Kas me leiame hiti kuskilt ja vaatame ka staatus Tegelikult
Õpetaja: sisse. Saavad logida ainult need vennad, kes on aktiivsed, Saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: See See on Niukene võimalus, kuidas Me saame niiöelda kedagi näiteks deaktiveerida.
Õpetaja: Kas jäädavalt ära kustutada? Rida ei taha. See on soft eliit
Õpetaja: jääda. Sellepärast kuskil on mingi miljon kannet. Vaata, mis on user Id ga seotud. Väga keeruline on seda asja ära kustutada.
Õpetaja: Siis kõik tabelid, kus vähegi on number kolmele viidatud user Id.
Õpetaja: Pead need ka ära kustutama või midagi pead tegema. Vaata nüüd rippuma Ei saa jääda. Tegelikult keegi viitab nagu, et sellel tabelil on Niuke number. Siin on see Protection. See ongi relatsiooniline andmebaas.
Õpetaja: Meil on andmed omavahel seotud nende Id de abil. Primeri abil on seotud erinevad Andmed erinevad tabelid ja andmebaas. Manageerib seda, et ei saa mingisugust lollust olla. Meie tabelis, et sa ütled, et sellel vennal on rol neli lähed, vaatad rol Tabelisse, Vaatad, et pole niukest Id Andmebaas ei luba seda.
Õpetaja: Tema vastutab selle eest, et on, et kui me seame sellised suhted sisse, et siin on Foregi,
Õpetaja: Siis need numbrid peavad päriselt viitama. Niiöelda Primeri Giidele, mis on olemas.
Õpetaja: See on nagu see, et ühe Tabel Ühes tabelis on Primerigi
Õpetaja: teises tabelis. Sa võid temale viidata, et see number, aga sul on see andmebaasis seotud. On öeldud, et see on Foregi
Õpetaja: Siin Veerus hakkavad olema numbrid, mis viitavad teise tabeli veeru laidi.
Õpetaja: Kui need numbrid. Kui sa ei leia vasteid, siis on nagu et ei saa andmeid tekkida ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Nii okei, City tabel. Siit tulevad andmed. Let s go ee loo uus komponent. Ee,
Õpetaja: näete pilt. Ma ei tea, kas ta teeb selle lahti või ei tee.
Õpetaja: See on missioon nii
Õpetaja: loo. Uus vaatekomponentbox, mis koostatakse Ket Cities teenuse, No me paneme selle appi Siia juurde. On ju
Õpetaja: nüüd esimene valik seal. Dropdown is. Ah, ta läks eritmoodi Ma vihkama, Seda teeb, kus ma Saan tagasi minna?
Õpetaja: No hea küll, on nii siis nii. Ee, Esimene valik seal. Dropdown is on kõik linnad
Õpetaja: sellele valikule järgnevad kõik Linnanimed, mis tulevad Jasonist.
Õpetaja: Kas siin on kellegi küsimus, et mis sinna mõeldud?
Õpetaja: Okei, lähme edasi. Kõik linnad saab. On selline valik, mida saab valida, aga see valik ise ei tule. Jason, Sõnumist
Õpetaja: väljud on seotud konkreetse linna City Id Ga. Mäletad, me juba korra proovisime seda, Kus Selecti. Me tegime sealt täiesti. Alguses on nähtavad väärtused ja on seal taga mitte nähtavad väärtused, aga need on seotud iga Optioniga
Õpetaja: ja me Tahame, et. Ee. Siis siin. Dropdown is on täpselt nii, nagu siin on
Õpetaja: see pilt. Vaata, et meil on siin Tallinn Tartu Pärnu ja tegelikult Iga selle Option I taga on value. Mis tegelikult on siis selle linna Id, mis mängib kokku sellega, saate aru, Need andmed tulevadki Siit
Õpetaja: Back end siis ee. Saadab sõnumi sihukese vastusega. Mis asi see kast siin on?
Õpetaja: See on massiiv. Siin on üks objekt. Teine objekt, Kolmas objekt on nii.
Õpetaja: Igas objektis on väärtus. City Id City, Id City Id. Igas objektis on Cityname Cityname Cityname
Õpetaja: valikus. Mida on näha Pärnu Tallinn Tartu Taustal selle taga on välju. Üks, kaks, kolm, City Id, üks, kaks, kolm.
Õpetaja: Nii, Selecti vahetades peaks Child Komponent, Näete, vaade on pärand. Siin sees on Child City, Strop Town
Õpetaja: Ja selectivahetus Peaks aa Saatma Valitud linna city Id Proof Of concept I. Mõttes lisa Üks alert koos vastava infoga. See user Id. Ja ta juba näitab meile. Aga nüüd me ütleme, et ta hakkaks City Id D näitama.
Õpetaja: No ütleme, et tegelikult me. Las ta lihtsalt näitab. City Id
Õpetaja: Proof of concept. On see see alert Box tuleb meil Atm St.
Õpetaja: Me Tahame tõestada ära, et kui sina vahetad
Õpetaja: seda linna, siis tema ütleb City Idi Kaks City idee kolm või City idi üks saate, aru,
Õpetaja: Sest et selle peale me peame, peab midagi muud hakkama hiljem toimuma. Meil on vaja näidata, et me suudame panna selle asja reageerima, et Barentis hakkavad mingisugused asjad pihta.
Õpetaja: See lõppeesmärk on see, mis meil oli siin. Sellel joonisel. Teen korra lahti. Aa, tuletage mulle meelde, et ma Ütleks Triinu, et ta prindiks välja rohkem
Õpetaja: pra. Meil on rohkem vaja. Seda siis, kui läheb Back end I asjadeks, siis on meil minimaalselt vaja seda joonist, et oleks, silme ees.
Õpetaja: Aga siin on see sama asi, et meil toimub Childis.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, siin on see sama pilt. Ma Proovin Zoom Ida siia niimoodi. Kui saab
Õpetaja: meil plaan, on selline? Kas ma saan kuidagi veits paremale minna? Kui valitatakse, va valitakse, siis pärand saab teada City Id,
Õpetaja: mille abil me küsime? Vastava tabeli. Näete, Tallinn. Tallinn. Tallinn. Tallinn.
Õpetaja: Seda numbrit on meil vaja siit kätte saada. Tema on Child.
Õpetaja: See asi on pärand. See on jälle Child. Kaks Child. Ja kes nad on? Omavahel
Õpetaja: õde ja vend, onju? Siblings aga pärent on meil. Ee, see on see Dysfunctional Family.
Õpetaja: Me ei saa otse omavahel suhelda Kahjuks see voe ongi üks functional family, mis puudutab siblinguid,
Õpetaja: me Ei, saa omavahel suhelda otse.
Õpetaja: See vend ei saa sellele vennale otse öelda. Midagi saab ainult öelda. Pärandile saab öelda lapsele omavahel.
Õpetaja: Straight, ära. Siin nende vahel ei ole võimalik.
Õpetaja: Suhtlus käib läbi, üks on tuvi, teine on allavoolavad andmed. Props.
Õpetaja: Nii midagi taolist, et see asi tuleb meil teemaks.
Õpetaja: Aga praegult me tahame saada teada, et me saame selle City Id kätte.
Õpetaja: Davai see missioon, See on missioon.
Õpetaja: Okei teeme seda. Step by Step.
Õpetaja: Kas me oleme ühe korra teinud? Ee, ala. Mingisugust alamkomponenti.
Õpetaja: Kas me oleme juba teinud? Mis me oleme teinud?
Õpetaja: Jah, Oleme teinud ühe alam, mäletate? Võttis sisse Propsi ja nii edasi, on ju? Okei, Cool.
Õpetaja: Nii, aa. Me Nüüd hakkame samasugust asja tegema, Aga Nüüd ma näitan seekord, kuidas me mõned asjad teeme. Me tegime käsitsi. Tookord tegime talle. Propsi Lisasime sinna juurde. Mis see oli, Error message Või message.
Õpetaja: Ee, Propsi väärtuse. Noh, millest ma räägin? Ma räägin seda, et me tegime selle asja siin. Tegime käsitsi,
Õpetaja: tegime käsitsi selle faili, Panime nime ja nii edasi. Tegime Selection I. Panime võimekused siia midagi anda. Nüüd Me teeme veel nüüd komponente, aga nüüd me teeme natukene Targemalt juba, et me ei pea seda käsitsi päris tegema.
Õpetaja: Okei, nii, ee, Millest me alustame?
Õpetaja: Täpselt, Teeme uue haaru
Õpetaja: oma õpetaja pealt. Võtke Teie ka õpetaja Pealt. Õpetaja pole, et te lõpuks Merchite enda sinna ja panen. Õpetaja Aa Veb oli üheksa. Vist oli üheksa. Vajutan Create
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: Aa, Atms Views peab tulema Uus Aa Selectbox.
Õpetaja: Noh, Atmv. Alustame Step by Step.
Õpetaja: Siia peab tulema kuskile Selectbox Kui vaadata seda asetsust, Siis kus kohas ta peaks asetsema?
Õpetaja: Vasakul pool.
Õpetaja: Ee, kaks kolumnit. Aga meil on praegu siin. See Heeder on ühe kolumni sees.
Õpetaja: Ma pakun, et teeme ühe uue. Paneme selle vana rohu juba kinni. Niimoodi, et ta ei häiri meid. Las tema Las see header olla puhtalt seal eraldi. Sest Tema hakkab keskel olema. On ju
Õpetaja: eraldi rau eraldi Kolum hoiab keskele. Me teeme ühe uue Tv I Biv tab.
Õpetaja: Paneme, et See class, et saas
Õpetaja: sina endale stiili mõttes rohutada.
Õpetaja: Rau Tuleme siia sisse. Kirjutan siia. Div Tab Enter, tulen siia, kirjutan Class Column.
Õpetaja: Kolm.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: mis nüüd edasi siia sisse peaks Tulema? Nüüd, ee. See sama Select asi mis mõtted on, Kui tahame mingit Html elementi,
Õpetaja: vaata, muidu On see lektor ja Nii edasi. Aga mis mõtted on?
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma võtan Select plussi, siis ta teeks nagu mingi põhja ettevõtte Selecti Ja mingi optioniga. Aga mis mõtted võiks olla kõigepealt?
Õpetaja: Noh, võtame natuke sellele kujundusele ja kõige sellele, mis mõte võiks olla,
Õpetaja: mis me teeme, Kuhu me läheme?
Õpetaja: No, kui ma tahaks mingit tabelit siia või input I midagi
Õpetaja: on, Ee, okei. Mm, Kui ma tahaksin tabelit siia teha Mingit tabelit ma teen.
Õpetaja: Kas ma tahaksin teha seda tabelit ilma igasuguse kujunduseta ja siis hakata seda ise kaunistama Või Boots Trap,
Õpetaja: kui me Tahame mingit Htm elementi. Siis läheme esialgu vaatame, et kas äkki Me saame selle mingil kujul juba mingi stiili Ja kõigega
Õpetaja: siis Läheb bootsrap I Bootsrap. I
Õpetaja: link on juba olemas. Ta läheb sinna, Gridi. Sellega. Meid ei huvita,
Õpetaja: vaid siit. Aa, me tahame otsida mitte on üks teistsugune variant. Aga me ei eelista seda praegu, et me tahame selle elektri.
Õpetaja: Kirjutate lihtsalt selectivõitate entrit.
Õpetaja: Näete, siin on Niukene menüü, eks See Mingi rondiga ja kõigega.
Õpetaja: Seal on jälle mingid large Ja saate vaadata igast variante, on ju? Saad mitut rida valida,
Õpetaja: bla, bla, bla, bla, Nii edasi. Meile sobib see kõige esimene variant. Lihtsalt Select Button One to three
Õpetaja: Võtame selle lihtsalt copy.
Õpetaja: Tuleme. Paneme selle siia Colli ära.
Õpetaja: Noh, Ei, tahtnud tulla.
Õpetaja: No kui nüüd tuleme, vaatame lehel.
Õpetaja: Admin üks. On kolm on siin. Select
Õpetaja: vist natukene. Tundub, et on vähe liiast
Õpetaja: Mingi maailma kõige laiem. Selectbox Ever, onju?
Õpetaja: Mis mõtted on? Kuidas saab, teda väiksemaks Ta on praegu kogu ulatuses on see on vist vihjed sees. Juba. Kogu ulatus on nii Lai
Õpetaja: tahaks veits kitsamaks. Mis tööriista olen ma õppinud juba?
Õpetaja: Kas varasemalt Oleme nagu mingis, Mäletate Alert Box oli mingi Monster Lai ja
Õpetaja: selle kooli sees. Meil saab olla siis lisaatribuut lühikuga saame panna kolm sidekriips
Õpetaja: ja näiteks nüüd siin saaks olla Ühest kaheteistkümneni kaksteist. Kui ma panen, ongi kogu see laius.
Õpetaja: Kui Ma panen siit ee näiteks kümme siis, kogu sellest võimalikust laiusest Hetkel
Õpetaja: On Natukene vähem.
Õpetaja: Okei, üks asi. Mul hakkab pinda käima. See alert kogu aeg. Võtame selle siit maha. Üldse Praegult Ee, kommentaariga.
Õpetaja: Ta hakkab kogu Aeg närvidele käima. See alert muidu nii. Aga meie loomulikult ei taha, et on mingi kolm, kümme, vaid, pigem lausa mingi ma. Ei tea Kolm, kaks, või kolm, Kolm Midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Vaatame näiteks koeraga.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma ei tea, käib kah pärast. Tiimib seda
Õpetaja: nüüd. Kuida, millest see lekt koosneb, on see, et kõigepealt on Select. Ise on ju
Õpetaja: Select ise. Ja siin on Id
Õpetaja: Selected. On see, et vaikimisel valitud
Õpetaja: panna juurde Niukse atribuudi, nagu tahaks. Me ei taha seda panna, muidu. No see on see, et saad korra valida, aga enam seda ei saa valida, on ju?
Õpetaja: Seda me ei soovi, aga nagu lihtsalt tuletame meelde.
Õpetaja: Meil taaskis on esiteks öeldud. Midagi taaskis on öeldud, et, ee, esimene valik, on kõik li hinnad
Õpetaja: Sellele valikule järgnevad valikud. Ee, linna nimed, mis tulevad. No, kõigepealt see esimene valik peaks olema
Õpetaja: kõik linnad. No võib Natuke disaini ka teha. Paneme mingi sidekriipsud. Näiteks kõik linnad.
Õpetaja: Aa, midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Kõik linnad. Noh, kole Näeb. Välja muidugi. Vabandust, midagi niimoodi Okei, Kindlalt
Õpetaja: on nii,
Õpetaja: nii?
Õpetaja: Okei, Mõtleme,
Õpetaja: kui mina praegu võtaksin. See on vaatamise koht hetkel, kui mina praegu ee võtaksin praegu ma teen isegi korra siia vahepeal ära. Ee, mis meil on? Feb? Üheksa
Õpetaja: See on minu minu värk. Ma tahan back Ida Hästi, kiirelt. Ma panen work In progress üks.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma võin push ida ka, aga ma loodan, et keegi praegu veel kohe järgi ei pea tulema vast ikka. Jõudsite Ee, olla niiöelda joonel.
Õpetaja: No vaata, mis see koht on.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tahaksin sellest teha eraldi komponente.
Õpetaja: Ma ei pea minema siia komponentide alla tulema. Parem klõpsed vä
Õpetaja: vahetad. Kui me meetodeid oleme siin ekstraktil Võtad mingi koodilõigu. Ja ütled tee, sest eraldi meet
Õpetaja: siin saab samamoodi teha Selle Html osaga. Sa pead ainult jälgima. See on vaatamise kohta, sest et ma ei kavatse seda veel teha. Ee, control alt. M ei Ole nüüd, see meetodid. Me ei taha teha
Õpetaja: nüüd vaikimisi. Ei olegi siin ühtegi shortcut. Kui tahaks, saaks selle tekitada selle shortcut ega ei viitsi seda teha. Nii vähesed kohad on Need on, kes tahavad. Teeks lihtsalt parema klõpsu
Õpetaja: ja mina võtaks siit refaktor ja pakkuge, mis siit võiks valida.
Õpetaja: Ja et võta see kood siit välja. Tee sellest voekomponent. Jällegi, ärge tehke. Praegu seda kaasa.
Õpetaja: Seisab siin peal. Ta juba kutsub välja mingi komponenti. Vaadake mis vaikimisi on Tema See, ee. Niiöelda konventsioon Camel Case kahe küüruga algab suure tähega onju?
Õpetaja: Siia ma peaksin siis kirjutama mingisuguse asja. Meil oli siin öeldud idee järgi. City oli vahet. Pole Midagi taolist
Õpetaja: Siis mina saaksin kirjutada Citys Drop Down
Õpetaja: vajutan entrit Nüüd ta Failini alguses tuleb täpselt sinna Samma kohta, Kust seest ma seda koodi ekstraktin.
Õpetaja: Kui mina olen Atms Views siis ta tuleb siia Failina kõrvale, on ju? Mis ta taustal teeb Ära Impordi loob. Vaadake, import tuleb siia ja siia. Siia. Blokki tuleb Components ja viidatakse, et Kuskil siin kasutame City Stop Town I Ta. Teeb kõik meie eest suht hästi ära
Õpetaja: aitan. Enter.
Õpetaja: Tuli selline komponent eksport. Default Mis, Ta nüüd tegi, On see, et ta teeb praegu seda stiili. Ee, mis päriselt. Siis peaks justkui olema, et skript tuleb. Kõigepealt ta tuleb templeid Minule see asi ei meeldi. Mina vahetaks ära selle järjekorra praegult
Õpetaja: niimoodi. Ärge tehke midagi kaasa. See on prügiesti kaup, aga idee järgi tegin Niukse komponendi valmis Sobib
Õpetaja: nii väga, Väga cool. Kõik asjad tulid siia. Import
Õpetaja: komponents. Et siin Selles Ee, vaatekomponendis kasutame mingit komponenti. Nüüd tekkis Ta Relationship Ka see on pärand. See on Child.
Õpetaja: Kui ma teen kohe nüüd rolback i teen
Õpetaja: teen ja kustutan ära ka selle faili Oleks võinud selle tikpoksi sealt isegi valida. Kustutan ära ka selle faili.
Õpetaja: Just mõtleme nii kaua. Nii
Õpetaja: oletame. Ma korra teen lihtsalt siia, Ma Panen siia. H. Üks korra. See on jälle vaatamise koht. A Üks
Õpetaja: kui mina siin sees. Näiteks kasutaksin atribuuti value mida teeb Välju
Õpetaja: Mina Näiteks programmiliselt. Tahan öelda, et siin Heederis on. Tere, lähme vaatame kõigepealt siin.
Õpetaja: Ma ei mäleta, kas see tegelikult ikkagi saab väljud panna, Ta ei ole interaktiivne. Okei, ma teen teistmoodi. Vahet pole, Ma teen niimoodi, et ma panen siia sisse, kui ma teen tagide vahel, soovin kasutada Näiteks, ee.
Õpetaja: Aa. Siin ei ole ühtegi muutujat. Ei ole veel isegi datablokis. Okei, ma ei saa praegu seda veel näidata, siis
Õpetaja: aga ma teen. Ma teen tegelikult mingi muuta. Las ta jääb siia. See on praegu ka veel. Vaatamise koht on ikka user. Id, on ju,
Õpetaja: on Ju
Õpetaja: ma tahan teha siia headerisse, et ee, saaks selle user Id väärtuse. Veel Parem on string ka veel tekst.
Õpetaja: Panen siia näiteks rolli nimi, Koolon. Ja nüüd ma soovin saada seda role. Name I,
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma saan esiteks anda märku? Vaata, et ee. Praegu Ma panen siia Rolli nimi on nii?
Õpetaja: Panen natuke, Võibolla väiksemad. No, vahet pole lihtsalt olla seal, suur et see on ajutine kaup niikuinii pan mingi
Õpetaja: väiksem Mingi rolli nimi.
Õpetaja: Ma olen Tagide vahel. Kuidas ma saan viidata sellele data bloki elemendile? Otse ei saa, kui ma panen lihtsalt Vabandust, Role Name. Kui ma lihtsalt panen roll name, siis ta paneb nagu selle stringina. Jah, mitte ainult, vaid lausa
Õpetaja: topelt nii vastab tõele, et ta Nüüd Praegu näitab siin seda sisu. Kui ma pean. Refresh
Õpetaja: on Advin tuleb sealt seest. Onju, et see taustal leitakse ülesse see on seal olemas,
Õpetaja: kui mina praegu. Kas vastab tõele, et mina praegu tahan kasutada mingisugust dünaamilist sisu, mis kuskilt tuleb läbi muutuja, on nii
Õpetaja: kui mina Praegu sooviksin seda siin kasutada Ja kui mina Select Iksin sellise koodi lõigu. See on see Select ise ja on ka see heeder sees Kui ma nüüd tulen, teen
Õpetaja: Ee Refactor Extract View komponent.
Õpetaja: Ta nüüd teeb uuesti selle komponendi. Aga Ta teeb ühe väikse vahega pakkuge, mis See vahe on
Õpetaja: ta on See osa on seal. Faisis või
Õpetaja: see? Ei, no see osa on nii. Või Naa, Vaata, et kõik, mis Ma Valin on seal. Vahet pole, kas ma valiks Pra. See vahe on. Kas ma valin niimoodi?
Õpetaja: Ma Mõtlen lõppkomponendis või ma valin niimoodi. Me Ei, räägi ainult sellest reast. Aga mingi üks mõtteline vahe on veel. Seal.
Õpetaja: See on data ga seotud ja. Aga kuidas?
Õpetaja: Kas vastab tõele. Vaata, et kui praegult. Kui mina tahan seda rolli nime siin kasutada, see väärtus võetakse ja näidatakse. Siin on ju admin,
Õpetaja: aga kui Mina teen sellest Child komponend I.
Õpetaja: Kui ma teen laps komponendi, siis see ei ole kirjutatud. Admin ju siin ei ole. Vaata rolli nimi Admin.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et tekib lapskomponent, kus on mingisugune Html osa, mis on täpselt nii, nagu on koodi sisse kirjutatud. Kõik Lilla linnad One to Free Onju,
Õpetaja: Aga on mingisugune osa. Heeder Neli rolli nimi Ja siis tuleb mingi väärtus. Aga see väärtus on ju mul siin, Mitte selles lapskomponendis. Aga kuidas ta siis sinna lapskomponenti saab?
Õpetaja: Sql Sql. Iga ei saa midagi. See väärtus on siin sees olemas, siin on Ju siin on sildikene. Kus on admin?
Õpetaja: Kuidas jõuab see Child I See sõna. Admin.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ta sinna jõuab?
Õpetaja: Kuidas viib data kaasa Child komponenti.
Õpetaja: Kuidas saab lapsele anda mingit informatsiooni pakikest
Õpetaja: Propsiga? Kui minul on praegu siin, ju see ei ole teksti. Vaata, see ei ole sisse kirjutatud vaid. See on mingi dünaamiline väärtus. Need on ju andmed.
Õpetaja: Kui minul on vaja seda adminit või mis iganes seal sees on kaasa anda. Vaata, mis iganes siin sees on,
Õpetaja: siis need andmed ju praegu. Selles failis on viitega ju databloki elemendile. Kuidas saab siis alumine Child ka midagi teada. Sest et Child I peab tulema. Täpselt selline kood, nagu siin on, peab tulema Role Name,
Õpetaja: mis väärtus tuleb dünaamiliselt, et Kui ma nüüd teen sellest Refactor ja Extract New Component.
Õpetaja: Vaadake juba praegu. Siin on näha,
Õpetaja: mida ta tahab teha. Tema ütleb, et
Õpetaja: sellest Childist. No ma panen City Strop. Ta on siia niimoodi kirjutanud. Cities.
Õpetaja: Tema teeb niukse komponendi Aa City ees.
Õpetaja: Siis tema ütleb, et seal all on Props nimega Role. Name. Palun anna kaasa Role name. Näete, see alt läks põlema. Vaata nii, vaadake korra. Rida kakskümmend, neli. Minu ekraanilt. Niipea kui ma lähen nüüd roll, name ile. Vaata, Läheb põlema ja tema ütleb, et all on Property nimega Role Name, anna talle väärtust Role Name ist
Õpetaja: kaasa.
Õpetaja: Miks on see kool on siin ees palun, Kui see praegult ei kõneta, siis te peate just vaatama neid Md Faile neid õpetusi seal eraldi Räägib sellest koolonist ka. Mida see kool annab märku.
Õpetaja: Võtan selle kooloni ära. Midagi muutus siin kohe.
Õpetaja: No Ta nüüd juba vist tegi Selle komponendi Veel ei teinud.
Õpetaja: Roheline, ah? Ma ei saa teha niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Mida see koolon teeb?
Õpetaja: Mi, Miks Miks on siin. See kool on vajalik.
Õpetaja: Ta. Ta ütleb seda. Vaata, et kui seda vaata. See on atribuudi nimi hetkel. See on nagu atribuut
Õpetaja: Tag i Attribuut rehkendubsiks.
Õpetaja: See kool on ütleb, et see asi tuleb muutujast.
Õpetaja: Ma teen selle komponendi ära, Mida me jäämegi siia Noh, läks New Komponent väga tore.
Õpetaja: Paneme siis jälle korra.
Õpetaja: Aa, nüüd ei ole seda heederit. H. Neli.
Õpetaja: Ma panen kohe topelt loogilised sulud. Ee, nii Teen ka selle uuesti.
Õpetaja: Teen selle valmis ära. Siis On on mida vaadata, muidu ta kaob kogu aeg ära. Mult on ju Cities
Õpetaja: Proptown.
Õpetaja: Vajutan entrit ära.
Õpetaja: Ad pani selle template osa siia alla. Jumal, temaga tõstan ta ülesse. Mulle tõesti meeldib niimoodi rohkem vaadata.
Õpetaja: Täpselt sama koodi Lõik nii nagu, ee, mis peabki lõpuks olema selles Atm is viiuses. Noh, see oli meie soov,
Õpetaja: aga nüüd on niimoodi. Vaata, et see Data bloki info elab mul siin sees.
Õpetaja: See info antakse alla Childile kaasa läbi Propsi. Kui ma siia peale,
Õpetaja: siis ma kukun siia juurde, on nii?
Õpetaja: Seda roll Name I on siin kasutatud. Järelikult seda näidatakse. On Admin.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tuleme selle kooloni juurde. Kui ma selle kooloni ära Võtan siit,
Õpetaja: siis see läheb siin roheliseks. See on string ja tulemus on role. Name.
Õpetaja: Koolon annab märku atribuudi ees, et sisend paremal pool ei ole string, vaid tuleb mingist muutujast.
Õpetaja: Me peame paari asja meeles hoidma. Koolonit loogilist sulgu vissi. Peame meeles hoidma.
Õpetaja: Veits ajab harjumust, aga See on see iga kord, kui mingid atribuudid. Kas on atribuut?
Õpetaja: Noh, ma ei tea. Ütlen, et sa üldse ole. Ma ei tea, mis juhtuma hakkab siis üldse?
Õpetaja: No see siin. Ta ei oska rehkendada seda. Vaata, on ju? Aga vahet pole
Õpetaja: klassile. Ma saan ka dünaamiliselt anda Mingist muutujast sisu. Näiteks
Õpetaja: siis ma panengi kooloni ette ja annan märku. Vaata, et ei, ei, ei, nüüd on mingi muutuja. Noh, ma ei tea, saate mõttes aru. Need on kõik atribuudid.
Õpetaja: Props on ka nagu siin kontekstis. Atribuut. Ja kui sa tahad anda mingist muutujast sisu, sa Pead talle märku andma, et Nüüd, ära mõtle seda kui stringi siin vaid, et kuskilt hakkab dünaamiliselt soovitagi teha. Näiteks, et, ee, mingi mingisugune Asi on punane. Mingisugune asi on roheline. Vastavalt andmetele.
Õpetaja: Noh, kuidas me teeme disaini
Õpetaja: Cssi? Me kasutame valdavalt klassidena. Kasutad klassi atribuuti aga sa Pead dünaamiliselt ütlema. Näiteks saate aru siis dünaamiliselt tahame seda sisu teki seda Ee, stiili muuta. Siis niimoodi saame
Õpetaja: nii, okei,
Õpetaja: nüüd meil on hea teada. Lihtsalt seda, et kui sul on plaanis teha niukest Aa Propsi, mis saab mingisuguse info kätte? Siis on küsimus. On lihtsalt nagu Selles, et millal. Millal teha Niiöelda kontroll, et võtab tagasi asjad.
Õpetaja: Vaatame
Õpetaja: viimase asjaga hakkama ei saanud. Näed, kui hea kui Rolback. Ee, see Küsimus ongi see, et millal on õige aeg teha komponent plaanitavast koodist.
Õpetaja: Nii ma nüüd näitan nagu millal ei tohiks seda teha. Vaata,
Õpetaja: kui Meil oli see sama H, Üks ja või A. Neli, onju? Ja ma kasutan seda praegult hetkel.
Õpetaja: Te võite disainida kõik asjad oma vaates Nagu selles mõttes kasvõi mingi tammi andmetega näed. Kõik linnad One to free. Te võite disainida nagu selle layout I oma projektides valmis, kui Te hakkate mingit vaadet tegema
Õpetaja: ja siis te võite hakata neid tükeldama niiöelda alamkomponentideks
Õpetaja: kui neil on see kõik valmis ja kui te juba Siin Praegult kasutate kõike neid muutuja nimesid, ehk andmeid. Niiöelda muutujate nimedena. Kui te lõpuks teete selleks niiöelda alamkomponendi, siis kõik Propsid on juba Olemas
Õpetaja: ei pea hakkama neid ise juurde lisama käsitsi kogu seda asja püsti panema. Saate mõttes aru. Aga nüüd on üks väike, Aga
Õpetaja: vaadake, Mis juhtub, siis Ma teen selle lihtsalt ühe. Mingi patani.
Õpetaja: Ma teen Button.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis ei taha tulla?
Õpetaja: Vaatan submit.
Õpetaja: Mingi nupp. Vahet pole, Mida see nupp teeb? Ma ei anna talle isegi stiili. Ma teen siia meetodi bloki peale. Tatar,
Õpetaja: te meetodi bloki meetods.
Õpetaja: Kool on neid Võibolla mitmeid.
Õpetaja: Pange koma vahele.
Õpetaja: Ma teen siia lihtsalt. Ee, tee midagi.
Õpetaja: Teeb midagi meetod, mis tegelikult ei teegi midagi, aga mul on ülisavi, No ma panen alert. Näiteks Ee alert
Õpetaja: Hei, nii kui mina panen näiteks mingisuguse meetodi siia nupu külge.
Õpetaja: Ät Click võrdub. Tee midagi nii Visuaalis on see nups ja tuleb ülesse. Vajutad. Tuleb alert.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see koodilõik. Tee midagi asub Siin
Õpetaja: Kui ma nüüd tahan võtta kogu selle teksti. Kus on see muutuja või Props Fine.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd siin. Kujutage ette, See kood läheb kuskile teise faili ära.
Õpetaja: Aga siin on ju viide mingisugusele meetodile, mis asub siin all.
Õpetaja: Nüüd sellega. Ta saab ka nüüd tegelikult hakkama. Aga see süntaks, mis nüüd siit hakkab tulema, saab olema üsna kole ja me seda ei soovi teha. Ma ütlen, et ole hea tee mul. Oota, aga kustuta niikuinii kõik ära. Ma ütlen, et tee sellest
Õpetaja: palun uus komponent,
Õpetaja: Siis ta annab alla meetodi. Kui Propsi näete, tee midagi, käivitab. Tee midagi, mis on siin, on? Nii
Õpetaja: Ma panen siia mingi New Component kaks. Lihtsalt teen selle valmis.
Õpetaja: Ma tõstan selle siia ülesse poole Ka mulle Üldse ei meeldi, et ta kogu aeg nii teeb, Kui ma saaks seda ära muuta. Näete, siin klikk on. Tee midagi, mis täidab Propsi. Tee, midagi mis tuleb lõpuks siia sellesse
Õpetaja: ja käivitab. Tee midagi Aga siin nüüd tekib nagu abstraktsioon.
Õpetaja: Ma mõtlen seda, et te peate nüüd seda asja nagu tervikuna ise mõtlema, et Propsiga läheb alla nagu mingi meetod,
Õpetaja: mis kuidagi käivitab nagu üleval. Siin tekib nagu niimoodi, et need asjad on omavahel nagu kuidagi niimoodi seotud, et see muutub segaseks. Kuhu ma. Üritan sellega tüürida, On see. Ma ütlengi, et see tegevus ei peagi tulema siia komponentide Võibolla peabki seal olema.
Õpetaja: Meil on oma suhtlusviisid. Kuidas me käivitame asju, kui on vaja, et kui te hakkate tegema mingisugust ee seda Ee Malli, Te hakkate tegema oma mingi visuaalset kujundust oma veebilehel.
Õpetaja: Te teete selle valmis. Te võite sinna juba panna ära kõik need muutujad, kus tulevad Mingid andmed ja info.
Õpetaja: Võite neid kasutada, Aga niipea, kui tuleb mingisugune ät Click ja käivita mingi meetod, siis siis seal tõmbab ka piiri. Vaata, Praegu ärge tehke neid funktsionaalsed meetode mingeid asju.
Õpetaja: Kujutage seda komponenti ette. Küll tõesti Seda, et on ainult nagu visuaalne komponent, kuhu sisse Lähevad mingid andmed
Õpetaja: Ehk niipea, kui hakkad juba mingeid ee meetodeid välja kutsuma. Selles koodilõigus,
Õpetaja: kus sa kirjutad? Seal on aeg nagu tõmmata pidurit. Ärge hakake arendama funktsionaalsust. Kui mõte on, see et Davai paneme paika. Siin saab olema mingi tabel. Siin saab olema mingi dropdown. Siin saab olla mingi pilt bla. Ka Selle asja panete paika ja selle võite juba ära teha. Kus Tammi andmetega?
Õpetaja: Ja ma ütlen, et tammiandmed, nagu Palun väga ee tammiandmed ju. Saad ju teha niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Sa planeerid ette ära, kui ma tulen. Ee, siia tagasi.
Õpetaja: Ma teen mingisuguse muutuja kiirelt siit mingi muutuja
Õpetaja: noh, ja ma saan panna, et ta on mingi string ja tal on mingi mingi sisu.
Õpetaja: Te saate juba seda kasutada üleval.
Õpetaja: Kui see on mingi objekt. Te saate selle subjekti isegi valmis teha. Näiteks, Noh,
Õpetaja: paneme, et see mingi first name.
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: noh, see Võib olla üldse hoopis mitte muuta, vaid person.
Õpetaja: Te saate põhimõtteliselt selle asja ka valmis teha. Okei, need andmed tulevad pärast Back end ist, Te saate siit nagu nendele viidata, Et nagu ma ei tea, teedki mingi komponendi. Ee, Mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Saate mõttes aru, te saate sellest Te Saate sellise asja nagu otsast lõpuni valmis teha kui tahate. Ja siis on see koht Davai. Nüüd teeme komponendid, eks? Ega see kogu see Ei, jää meile ju siia. Vaata, on ju vaid. On ikka alamkomponendid.
Õpetaja: Aga niipea, kui te hakkate siin, et, oot, oot, mingi meetodi ja Siin kutsun välja ja plaan on see kuskile mujale ära viia. Vaata, siis on see koht, et funktsionaalsust veel ei arenda. Polegi mõtet, polegi Päris andmeid veel, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga te saate alguses teha rahulikult oma need komponendid ära.
Õpetaja: Kui teie jaoks, Nagu seda raske nagu manageerida, vaata et mida kasutada või mitte, see on ka täiesti okei. Ma teen jälle selle.
Õpetaja: Päris objekti. Suudab stringiks ka teha. Ma ei tea, ei, ei, Oleks saanud vist. Jah. Ma oleks pidanud nagu panema punkti ka.
Õpetaja: Aga see ei ole mu mõte. Kui te tahate, kui te saate props Alati suht lihtsalt hiljem juurde ka tegelikult lisada. See ei ole nigu väga keeruline, et isegi kui sa te teete niimoodi, et te teete Mingi layout I ära. Ja siis hakite niimoodi. Ekstrakt, komponent, ekstrakt, komponent. Aa Siis on juba päris hea
Õpetaja: Ee, Jah, natuke ettenägelikud. Kui te Juba mõtlete need andmeobjektid ka ära, mis? Neil hakkavad seal konkreetselt selles vaates toimetama. Teha. Ära need muutuvad Databloki kasutada Neid ekstrakteid on natukene, Võidate aega. Kindlasti on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga funktsionaalsust ei tohi selles, etapis veel arendada, Et meetodeid ei kutsu kuskilt Highlight It koodist välja.
Õpetaja: Siis lähevad asjad juba veits nagu rappa ja on Pärast on käsitööd.
Õpetaja: Okei, liigume edasi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. Aa, meil ongi plaan. Tegelikult.
Õpetaja: Ee, seda teha niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Aa, ma nüüd teen. Kustutan kõik siit ära. Nüüd on hakkame kaasa. Tegemise koht.
Õpetaja: Aga Kas teil nii palju on, et teil on need see Näidis on olemas kõik linnad. Ja mida iganes onju
Õpetaja: võib, võib korra natukene niimoodi eraldada. Vaata, et, ee, on asju näha.
Õpetaja: Ee, niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Hakkame mõtlema, et Ee. Mis sa taaski Ütled, mis juhtuma peab?
Õpetaja: Selectbox on tehtud. Esimene valik on. Kõik linnad järgnevad, linnad tulevad No hetkel on meil see One to three
Õpetaja: Ee. Nüüd meil ongi tähtis, see, et me peame hakkama tooma. Ära andmeid selle teenusega.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma muudan juba siit siis ära. Nagu tulevikut arves. Juba ka
Õpetaja: see teenus toob meile ära. Olete nõus?
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma stopplaid? Sain nüüd selle korda, aga Ma muutsin kõigile ära. Vist Mul tuleb meelde. Panin hapid ette. On ju?
Õpetaja: Äkki endiselt on vaja ära tuua andmeid City S,
Õpetaja: kui mina Ütlen nagu, et Back on back. Endist on vaja tuua ära Andmed Citys,
Õpetaja: Mis on meie nüüd järgmine samm, et kõik asjad läheksid sujuvalt Ja Hästi, mis me tegema peaksime?
Õpetaja: On teil mingeid mõtteid?
Õpetaja: Meil on plaan hakata ehitama seda funktsionaalsust toa Ära anda.
Õpetaja: See on hetkel, mis Me tahame teha
Õpetaja: piibel täpi pealt. Õige Asi piibel.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast täna just ju vaatasime neid materjale ja seal rääkis et näed, et sul on Nagu leping niiöelda kahe osapoole vahel. Fronti Ja vahel on leping, et kui sina nagu pärid andmeid, siis sina pärid seda Correctselt nii nagu Mina sulle ütlen
Õpetaja: ja on meie piibel
Õpetaja: Praegult. On ta lihtsalt läbi. Stoplight, I genereeritud ja online svage. Hiljem on niimoodi, et te panete oma serveri käima. Back and serveri. Lähete ühele urlile ja seal näidatakse teil süsteemi süsteemi pealt genereeritud. Niiöelda svage
Õpetaja: nagu ruttu pannakse üks ütleme Linnulennult, kui teie käivitate serveri. Iga kord joonistatakse nagu Niukene väikene veebilehekülg uuesti. See on äge
Õpetaja: ja see peegeldab, kõike mis veebiteenusetel elektrisüsteemis on Automaatselt teie eest.
Õpetaja: Ja see on teie piibel, et selle järgi teie hakkate siis ju asju tegema.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis seal siis ikka Läheme Svägerisse Praegult on siis see sväger editor.
Õpetaja: See Ee, te peaksite ka seda tegema. Te tahate seda asja kaasa teha.
Õpetaja: See peaks veel endiselt olema Meel meeles niiöelda need teenused, mis sai antud.
Õpetaja: Ahhaa, ee jah. Ee. Teeks väikse uuenduse ka. Ma olen korra Stoplight I
Õpetaja: ee kuskil juhuslikult lahti vist ei ole. Teeme uuesti. Ma arvan teile, uuend. Mäletate, et urlid muutusid ju appi.
Õpetaja: Ma annan ee teile uuendatud Ee Jason I General Kanalis selle jaoks. Ma lihtsalt lähen ise siia projekti sisse.
Õpetaja: Ma lähen Edit. Vaatesse
Õpetaja: Mhm
Õpetaja: Ütlen, et näita mulle kogu seda asja nagu Jasonina nii nagu see tehnoloogia. Tegelikult taustal ongi. Seda ei ole Stoplight välja mõelnud. See standard Open appi.
Õpetaja: See on hoopis kellegi teise poolt Väljaarendatud sväger on üsna tihedalt nendega seotud ka nii. Mina võtan kogu selle asja. Ee, mul peaks veel dokument Download I all peaks olema Kuskil
Õpetaja: ma teen. Selle editi ka lahti.
Õpetaja: Panen selle siia asemele, Panen Control S ja tulen lihtsalt. Ee, Tulen lihtsalt generali alla.
Õpetaja: Tulen topin selle niimoodi siia. Niimoodi. Põmm.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, kas te saate download nuppu kasutada. Vist on ju Kui Tulete sõnumi peale Download,
Õpetaja: kui sa ma Ei, tea, kas lahti. Ta teeb seda või mitte.
Õpetaja: Parem on lihtsalt download. Ida downloadis alla. Open containing folder.
Õpetaja: No Minul ta Nüüd on üks pani. Ta lihtsalt ei saa sama faili nimega salvestada vaikimisi ja
Õpetaja: panete kuskile downloads kausta Ja siis te tulete sellesse sväger editorisse tagasi. Ja siin on Niukene fail ja importfil.
Õpetaja: Ja impordime selle sama asja sisse uuesti, mis te just downloadisite
Õpetaja: ja nüüd peaks olema urlid Koos papidega. No minul tulid appi. Appi, Appi, appi, appi.
Õpetaja: Abi. Happ
Õpetaja: file, importfil.
Õpetaja: No, minul. Oli Ta all aga kirjutajate svage reditor Google Sse.
Õpetaja: Kirjutad selle aadressi ka. Siis saab nii ka
Õpetaja: tulevikus. Me ei pea seda kasutama tulevikus. Me kasutame päris backendi pealt genereeritud praegult See on nagu päris hea peegeldus sellest väikeste. See on natuke detailsem kui Päris peegeldus.
Õpetaja: Seal on mingid näited. Asjad, mida saab juurde panna, aga Siis risustaks koodibaasi nii rõvedalt, et seda ei taha teha.
Õpetaja: Mis teenus meid huvitab
Õpetaja: Cities. Ee. Cities tagastab loetul linnades koos City Id ja City name väärtustega.
Õpetaja: Kui sa nüüd niimoodi lahti teha, siis mis meil siin võib huvitada? Parameeter siis ütleb No Parameeters
Õpetaja: respons on selline, mis Päris päris rakenduses on. Parem on see, et seal ei ole niukest eksemplit. Tallinn Tartu pärnu, vaid seal, on lihtsalt massiiv
Õpetaja: ühest objektist City Id Null City Name String Mudel on seal täpselt ees, mida me tahame panna. Ee, mujale.
Õpetaja: Noh, skeemad asjad. Siit saab veel Inf Üht Teist ühtegi ei ole, Välja arvatud internal server error, mis võib mis iganes asjaga tulla,
Õpetaja: siis see on meie piibel. See on siis see, Asi, mille me tahame. Ee, sättida endale vasakule. Niimoodi
Õpetaja: Te saate minu ekraani pealt ka vaadata. Nagu aga ainukene asi. Jah, et me peame vaatama, et mis teenus on ja nii edasi, on ju?
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui me läheme oma projekti, siis meil on üks süsteem
Õpetaja: sõnumite saatmiste osa, Kus meil see käib?
Õpetaja: Et Scriptis. Millises Scriptis
Õpetaja: mõte on? Nagu see, et me ei taha nagu siia veel midagi progeda. Me tahame teha Seda, et kui me tahame Back end ile saata sõnumi, siis me leppisime kokku oma mingi arhitektuuri ja süsteemi oma oma projekti ees, et Kuidas meie neid asju Teeme? Millele ma viitan.
Õpetaja: Kuidas kooleliga on? Atri atribuudi sees mingisuguse data muutuja Niiöelda defineerimine.
Õpetaja: Ma räägin seda, et me Tahame hakata programmeerima seda sõnumi saatmist,
Õpetaja: kus ja Kuidas me seda tahaks teha? Meil On oma süsteem.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: muutuja jaoks on veel vara Muutujat ei ole. Vaja. On vaja kirjutada java script ja küsimus, kuhu me kirjutan. Selle
Õpetaja: toome uue faili.
Õpetaja: Toome uue faili Ee. Mis faili? Kuhu Ee, samuti juurde
Õpetaja: Views all. Aga Viewal ju käivad ainult. Ee, vaated ju.
Õpetaja: Komponent. Kas me hakkame visuaalset komponenti Praegu tegema? Kuskilt tuli õige Vastus
Õpetaja: ja Api Services Backend. Sõnumid käivad kõik Meil läbi. Mäletate loogi. Indrek West tuleb meelde
Õpetaja: nüüd. Meie subjekt on Cities Kas City Sa võiks olla?
Õpetaja: Ei, sest et kuidagi ei haaku see temaatiliselt. Siis mis me teeme? Jaa, uue ja avascripti faili
Õpetaja: siia alla. Mis ta nimeks võiks minna.
Õpetaja: Miks, gets? Sest on juba tegusõna. Vaata
Õpetaja: aga miks. Mitmuses, kui ma oleme potentsiaalsed, mida me saaksime City City, mis me siia Service I alla saaks. Panna. Idee järgi. Mõtleme lihtsalt andmete mõttes. Anname mulle kõik linna
Õpetaja: Siis sa võiksid just panna justkui panna City Service Vastab tõele, nagu ei ole mingit errorit.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis, kui me tahaksime panna. Siia Näiteks, ee,
Õpetaja: kui me tahaksime. No see ei oleks keelatud Ka kui me tahaksime siia nii öelda. Lisa uus linn, et mul on mingi admin vaade, kus mul on üks välia, et Lisa oleks Uus linn. Lihtsalt süsteem.
Õpetaja: Ei, ei, kindlasti mitte. Miks, miks mitte? Miks? See on lihtsalt script, mis saadab sõnumeid, mis? Kuidas Kui sa. Paned sõna. Siis Sa seod sellega juba millegagi. Ma tahan lisada
Õpetaja: Ee, Citiesid. Ma tahan ee, lugeda Citysid. Ma pigem nagu tahan seda, et kas Ta võiks olla ainsuses või mitmuses.
Õpetaja: Minule. Tundub, et mi Ainsus on nagu lihtsam sellepärast, et. Ee,
Õpetaja: aa, sest et siis kui sa näiteks Lisad ühte või loed ühte. Vaata siis see mitmus. Kuidagi on natuke nagu eksitab. See on muidugi jälle natukene. Äkki et kuidas kellelegi?
Õpetaja: Aga Mu mõte oli see, et see teema, millega ta ühel või teisel viisil saaks olla seotud, on linn.
Õpetaja: Siis mina paneks selle nimeks City
Õpetaja: Service. Kuidagi on ta seotud City andmetega.
Õpetaja: See poleks ee halb. Või kui ta oleks ka mitmuses,
Õpetaja: Ta võiks nii olla. See on siis kokkuleppeline, aga meie lepime ju, kokku et me teeme ainsuses
Õpetaja: hiljem. Eriti kui me teeme, siis see on nagu joonistad välja ka miks,
Õpetaja: nüüd, et seda komponenti oleks mu kuskil mujal võimalik kasutada, Siis mis ma siia kõigepealt kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Eksport, default ja loogilised sulud algavad ja enter võib juba paar rida lüüa. Siia ka
Õpetaja: nüüd siia. Me kavatseme teha meetodi,
Õpetaja: mis hakkab siis tegelikult Saatma sõnumit sellele endpointile.
Õpetaja: Mina juba leppisin kokku, Et Millest me alustame? Kui me tahame uut meetmit teha, siis mis me siin peame kõigepealt kirjutama?
Õpetaja: Meetodi struktuur, nüüd nagu funktsiooni struktuur, mis Ma kirjutan siia, millest alustame.
Õpetaja: See. See ei ole Jaova nimi.
Õpetaja: Siin. Minu idavaseentest tuleks ka sõna function aga see voe saab sellega ise hakkama.
Õpetaja: Ma kirjutan meetri nimi, mis võiks meetode nimi olla.
Õpetaja: Ja me leppisime kokku, et me hakkame ütlema igakord lihtsalt Cities Request
Õpetaja: see on hästi tehniline, aga täpselt seda ta teeb
Õpetaja: Cities mitmuses. Miks? Sellepärast, et ta tagastab ju Massiivi Ma ei saa öelda, siis annab meile mitu linna,
Õpetaja: et see peab mõlemat pidi mööda tegelema.
Õpetaja: See tuleb nüüd urli pealt, onju? Seda upit ma ei hakka. Muidugi ütleme see ja et See on sõnum, mis läheb välja, on Request.
Õpetaja: Meil on sõnumitel alati kaks Poolt Request Response
Õpetaja: päring Vastus päring, vastus, päring, vastus inglise keeles, Requestres. Need sõnad mängivad siin seal ka kaasa.
Õpetaja: Nii ma natukene eraldan jälle seda. Ta to hoopis selle just siia kokku.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see siis hakkab seda tegema
Õpetaja: nüüd. Praegu. Keegi seda välja veel ei kutsu. Vahet pole, Me programmeerime kõik ära, mis on praegu seotud sellega siin nii nii kaugele, kui saame.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kes päriselt hakkab seda sõnumit saatma. Nüüd on need koodiread, mida me ei taha. Vaata, et oleks seal kuskil hiljem. Kunagi.
Õpetaja: Mis me nüüd kirjutame?
Õpetaja: No kohe, lähme Teeme ka selle ära. Aga
Õpetaja: teeme viisteist minutit ja siis teeme täistooni. Lunchi sobib praegu, Oleme lainel veel. Vaata.
Õpetaja: Ja kes tegelikult saadab siis meie Brauserist selle sõnumi aktsias. See on tehnoloogia aktsias.
Õpetaja: Aktsias Paksusel on erinevad ee tegevused, Mida saab käivitada? Kuidas neid tegevusi saab üleüldiselt programmeerimises käivitada? Mis on see
Õpetaja: punkti abil, mis meid huvitab?
Õpetaja: See sama kett, mis juba ta pakub.
Õpetaja: Nüüd vaatame, mida. Mida Nagu siis. Aa,
Õpetaja: Mida siis siin praegult saab sisestada?
Õpetaja: Stringi Täpsemalt. Mida See, String representeerib, siis
Õpetaja: no ma praegu Mõtlen nagu muutuja nimi, mis on, seal nagu vihjeks meetodis. Parameetri nimi Url. Me peame Stringi kujul mingi urli seestama. Mis see Url on, meil. Siin.
Õpetaja: Jah, Ma saaks praegult seda siit Coopida No, pole. Maailma kõige pikem asi, mida ka ise kirjutada Get Cities.
Õpetaja: Okei, mida veel saab. Ee, mida? Mida see meetod veel saab? Aga ei pea ee vastu võtma.
Õpetaja: Ei, saab Errorit vastu võtta. Või peame kaasa andma Error I.
Õpetaja: Mida see meetod veel võimaldab? Nagu, et talle saab kaasa anda.
Õpetaja: Ma panen selle koma ära. Ma viitan sellele. Mis asi see on, Konfig sätted.
Õpetaja: Mäletate, millal meil oli vaja seda kasutada?
Õpetaja: Login i pealt. Saate vaadata siis, kui meil olid mingid parameetrid.
Õpetaja: Siis kui meil oli Header. Näiteks, et meil oli vaja logimisel öelda. Stoplight Ile.
Õpetaja: Kõik need saavad konfiga sisse minna. Kas meil siin on parameetreid selles teenuses, mida saab kaasa anda. Anna mulle mingid linnad ja saan veel öelda, et täpsemalt millised linnad ei ole. Ju
Õpetaja: siis seekord lähebki nüüd niimoodi, et Nagu see küsimärk näitab, et võib, aga ei pea siis. Sellel hetkel meil praegult on kokkulepe, et me ei anna midagi sinna. Kaasa.
Õpetaja: Parameetrid on? No parameeteris.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, mis puudutab sellesse osasse, et sõnumi saatmine Request osa saab siit otsa.
Õpetaja: Nüüd juba tuleb respons.
Õpetaja: Sellega meil siin rohkem Midagi ei olegi teha.
Õpetaja: See nüüd ongi sõnumi. Saatmise osa saab siin läbi.
Õpetaja: Pole mingit parameetreid. Pole mingeid asju, Midagi ka Stop Light il öelda ta annab niikuinii kogu aeg tallinntarupärnu või mis iganes need kolm linna kätte, on ju
Õpetaja: nii?
Õpetaja: Nüüd võiks jälle lugeda lõppenuks, aga siin On üks väikene mure, mis veel vajab nagu tegemist.
Õpetaja: Mis on veel vaja siiski teha? Ma ütlen sõnumi saatmisega on kõik nagu korrektne
Õpetaja: return I, et jah. See on täpselt see, nagu. Et päris nagu andmebaasist mingid andmeid. Aga sa ei tee sellega midagi. Sa ei pane muutu ühesse onju?
Õpetaja: No ma võiksime panna muutujasse ja siis ta siin läheb selles muutujas. Aga ta sureb seal muutujas ära et kogu see töö Läheb lihtsalt kuhugi siin. Selles meetodis lihtsalt kaob ära.
Õpetaja: Aga kui me ütleme siia lause ette, return,
Õpetaja: siis ütleb, et tema return töötab alati Niimoodi, et parem pool rehkendatakse kõigepealt ühel või teisel viisil ära.
Õpetaja: Ja siis käivitub return.
Õpetaja: Siin on see, et saada sõnum ja ta anna promissi, et kunagi vastan.
Õpetaja: See annab nagu toru. Annab üle. Sa saad toru anda. Üle. Sa tõmbad kõne ära nagu üks, üks, kaks
Õpetaja: ja Nüüd tuleb see muusika, et oled ootel nagu sul on eriti kiire. Ja Ootad on ju
Õpetaja: See return on ka enda. See. Vaata, et Annad toru nüüd nagu ülevaate kes? Tahab? Vaata, see oleks ka enda niimoodi, et minu, ee, kallis naine. Näiteks meil on mingi Merses juhtumas Maja põleb. Ma ütlen naisele, nagu. Kuule, ole hea naine, on mul See City Service Wife Service Service on seal saadaval.
Õpetaja: Ei, seda ma ei räägi. Ja seal on väga palju seaduseid. Ei ole. No mingi koristus. Teenused. Ja.
Õpetaja: Aa, et on see Wife Service. Ma ütlen temale Vaata, Wife Service.
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen nagu Wife Service Call One One Two Naine teeb seda
Õpetaja: jah. Kui, See retoorne on seal sees siis, ta annab toru üle. Ta annab promiss. Vaata, et keegi sulle vastab. Noh, võtan selle toru üle, Vaata ja siis nagu see ongi niimoodi, Palun Helista üks, üks, kaks ja anna telefon. See on Mi, see on minu. Me. See on meetod. Anna mulle,
Õpetaja: jätame ära.
Õpetaja: Panin. Tegid selle töö ära valis. Üks, kaks ära. Mul on seal. Ma ei tea kustutanud midagi juba või otsinud. Mingi veepange
Õpetaja: on ju samal ajal Naine teeb seda, mida ma palusin, et tema nüüd return, on see koht. Vaata, et kui. Kui ma nagu ütlen, vaata naisele nagu. Vaata, naine Wife Service. Helista üks, üks, kaks, ja anna toru. Kui ta lihtsalt helistab
Õpetaja: selle kõnega. Ta ei tee seda viimast asja, et Anna toru. Vaata seda ta ei tee, onju? Kett on ju? Kui ta. Kui ta seda osa nagu ei tee, siis on sellest nagu vähe kasu, Nüüd ma pean lootma, et mu naine nagu seal midagi räägib üks kahega ja mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Aga kui ma ikka tahan seda niimoodi sisse Retöörnu on see, et sa annad selle toru üle
Õpetaja: ja nüüd läheb aega ennem, Kui keegi Võibolla vastab, keegi teine. On seal ka üksus Kahes järjekorras. Võibolla mingi minutikes ootama või sekundid, mis tunduvad nagu minutid.
Õpetaja: See retoorne on Selle jaoks. See siin on Wifi Service,
Õpetaja: Helista üks, Üks, kaks ja anna toru.
Õpetaja: Anna mulle toru. Anna telefon, Nüüd Me lähemegi siia. Ee, kohta, kus me olnd oleme Mõtleme Natukene edasi,
Õpetaja: nüüd see nüüd, see on olemas.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, mis on meie missioon, on see, et me vaatame, mis see kell on. Teeme Veerandini. Nüüd. See missioon ongi nagu see, et meil on olemas teenus, mis hakkab tooma ära Citys andmeid.
Õpetaja: Nüüd meil on vaja. Mis see Hall? Tähendab?
Õpetaja: Nii, mina Küsin, et. Ee, aga kus me soovime seda kasutada?
Õpetaja: Views.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, Millal me soovime seda välja kutsuda? Seda teenust. Mille Millisel hetkel?
Õpetaja: Millal Me soovime seda välja kutsuda.
Õpetaja: Siis, kui me satume siia lehele Vaata siis. Põhimõtteliselt on vaja seda kohe. Vaja. Nii, kui lehele satume
Õpetaja: siis Praegult me saaksime seda asja. Noh, korra teen, et siin kõik, mis ma ütlesin, et vaata, mis Mountai sees on, käivitatakse, vastab tõele,
Õpetaja: kui Ma praegu tahaksin seda siin välja kutsuda.
Õpetaja: Mis ma siis kirjutaksin?
Õpetaja: Jah, Wifi. Wifi Service. Siin on City Service ja siis viitaks
Õpetaja: mis ma Tahan, onju siin. Ma tahaksin öelda. Helista üks, üks, kaks ja anna toru, on nii?
Õpetaja: Me saame nüüd seda siin selles Mountais. Teha ja See kõik tegelikult taustal toimib. Me juba võime kohe vaadata. Ma küsin teie käest, kuidas ma saan juba testida, kas see asi töötab või ei tööta.
Õpetaja: Mis on minu tööriistad? Nagu vahendid. Kuidas ma saan?
Õpetaja: No ei viitsi alerti teha praegu. Kuidas teistmoodi?
Õpetaja: Kuidas saaksin logida ka, aga veel lihtsam mida see teeb?
Õpetaja: See läheb käima. Aga kuidas me saame vaadata, et see läheb käima? Ma
Õpetaja: Okei, juba hakkab natuke lähemale minema. Läheme korra selle
Õpetaja: lehele tagasi. Tulen siia jälle. Ma ei taha minna. Nii, kuidas ma. Öelge, mulle? Mida Mis ma pean nüüd vajutama ja tegema.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma saan veenduda, et tegelikult saadetakse sõnum?
Õpetaja: Sest need on tööriistad, mida te peate mõistma
Õpetaja: kuidas, ma saan ma. Saan juba kontrollida Kas see asi vähemalt töötab?
Õpetaja: Kas tuleb mingeid probleeme või ei tule?
Õpetaja: Kuidas
Õpetaja: F. Kaksteist, mis edasi?
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: siit samast Siit ei ole midagi vaadata. Local Storage Isse. Ma ei ole progenud midagi, et peaks tulema. Sõnum läheb Backendi vastab tõele.
Õpetaja: Minu läpakas Siit läheb Minu brauserist läheb Sõnum teele.
Õpetaja: Kongoolist ei olnud.
Õpetaja: Ei, konsoolist ei näe konsooli. Ma ei ole midagi loginud.
Õpetaja: No ma panen refresh
Õpetaja: Mm, ei taustal. Ma Tean, et läheb sõnum. Mul on programmeeritud. Nii, Aga kuidas ma saan kindlaks seda teha? Ju praegu?
Õpetaja: Network.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tulen Network i all vaata, Juba seal näeb. Siin see Citys juba paistab, aga ma kusutan ära.
Õpetaja: Tere, Fresh.
Õpetaja: Kui mina tulen siia lehele, mountaed läheb käima Network Ist Minu Brauserist läheks sõnum teele Api Cities. Näete juba siit. Juba Highlights on näha
Õpetaja: status kakssada vastas tema Kui ma klikin peale, saan, lisainfot
Õpetaja: Api Citys läks Front and serverile. Front and server saatis selle Stop Light Ile edasi.
Õpetaja: Vaatan respons. Mida, mis? Kas ma sain midagi vastu Ka
Õpetaja: Tallinn, Tartu, Pärnu City, Id kaks, kolm, üks, on. I.
Õpetaja: Kuidas siis on? Midagi Valesti sul
Õpetaja: vastus on väga lihtne. Me vahetunni võime vaadata. Praegu ei huvita
Õpetaja: mi mul on. See printsiip on tähtis,
Õpetaja: Saite aru? Me juba saame midagi kontrollida,
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et kõik sõnumid, mis lähevad Backendi lähevad meie Browser is Browser. Isse inspekt lahti. Mine Network I alla ja vaata, mis lendab. Otso, siin on ka see tähtis. Vaata, et kas teil on all peal?
Õpetaja: Tuleb. Iga. Mäletad, ma rääkisin. Vaata, et Fetch Api
Õpetaja: Ee Browseris on olemas juba see programm Fetch, millega on võimalik saata. Sõnumeid saadab ka tegelikult sõnumeid läbi. Fetch I
Õpetaja: lihtsalt. Meil on nagu jälle Nagu ütleme, peal istub mingisugune raamistik, nagu mis on teeb meie eesti käest Fookust. Fookust
Õpetaja: Iraanis, Np.
Õpetaja: Nii põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: printsiibis. Saame teada, et töötab. Nüüd on küsimus see, vaata, et jah, ta Mountedis võiks olla, aga. Aga nüüd on see, et me hakkame tegelema vastuse kõigega, mida me ei tahaks teha, on see, et siia hakkab tulema mingisugust koodi.
Õpetaja: Me tahaks tegelikult, seda, et hoopis meil on eraldi meetod.
Õpetaja: Meil on eraldi meetod, mille me siin käivitame.
Õpetaja: Noh, tegelt Before Mount oleks isegi parem Ka Before Mount.
Õpetaja: Nii I love optimizing Mida iganes. Korra. Siin läks ilusti paika. Nüüd peale data bloki. No kuhu Me saame meetodeid kirjutada. Option, Cpi, S. Näete, need on kõik Option Id, valikud, valikud, valikud ongi. Niukene Option. Nagu
Õpetaja: siin elavad kõik meetodid siia. Me saame, öelda et hakkab olema üks uus meetod
Õpetaja: nüüd siin. Me tahame panna selle tegevuse nimeks Niukse Niukse äriloogilise või niukse üldise nimetuse, et mida? Mida ta teeb? Vaata,
Õpetaja: mida hakkab see tegevus tegema.
Õpetaja: No mida ta hakkab tooma te tegema Mis andmeid? Me hakkame tooma
Õpetaja: linna andmeid, siis mis võiks? Olla meetode nimi?
Õpetaja: Pilti peitu.
Õpetaja: Aa, mis see data? Nagu kõik asjad on meil siin andmed. Vaata iga asja kohta hakkame deita lõppu panema. Siis läheb rõvedaks.
Õpetaja: Gids, Cities.
Õpetaja: Vot see on kõige parem. Vot kui me teeme niukse meetodi nagu Get Cities
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd siia sisse Teeme siis selle asja, et. Ee, no mis see oli? Wifi Service City Service
Õpetaja: Call Nine One One on Pasta Phone
Õpetaja: City Service Saint Get Cities Request.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et siia hakkab nüüd seda koodi tulema, Mäletate ju? Hakkab koodi tulema. Nüüd tema elab siin. Selles meetodis Seda saab nüüd vaadata eraldi. Keegi tuleb siia sisse, vaatab Get Cities. Põmm. Get Cities mis siin toimub Vaatan, uurin ja nii Edasi
Õpetaja: on arusaadav. Okei, cool, cool, cool, cool, davai.
Õpetaja: Aa, kaks minutit on veel aega. No sellega ei jõua midagi enam ära teha,
Õpetaja: Amount I võib panna, et keegi mind ei tarbi, on nii?
Õpetaja: Hall Näitab seda, et keegi mind ei ole kunagi kuskil nagu kasutanud. Ega keegi ei ole mind kunagi ära kasutanud. Aga Ma soovin
Õpetaja: siis siin all me saame öelda, aga nüüd peab This ütlema ette, et siin selles Kuskil meil siin selle sees on Mingi meetod nimega
Õpetaja: Get Cities ja käib lõpuni. Need ka.
Õpetaja: Palun väga, Kõik on jälle. Nüüd korras? See on nüüd kommit I koht.
Õpetaja: Aa, Favorking Progress Kaks, kes tahab, tuleb peale Lunch I järgi. Kell üks. Oleme kõik tagasi. Sobib,
Õpetaja: kui Push Ib, Push, Ib ja saate siis vahepe vahetunnil järgi tulla. Kuule, ärme raiska lõuna aega lõunale.
Õpetaja: Pärast räägime Kui mingid tehnilised probleemid ja asjad on? Siis Me lahendame neid pärast.
Õpetaja: Ee, buss. Buss ka veel. Ja Let s go.
Õpetaja: Artur, Sul oli üldse andmebaasiga mingi mure? Kas see lahenes kuidagi väga hea.
Õpetaja: Ee, jah, Andmebaasis me ei tee
Õpetaja: ja me praegu õpime. Aga muidu me peaks, nagu
Õpetaja: me tegelikult teeme, me teeme tegelikult selle asja ümber. Ee, üldse. Vaata, tegelikult see on avalik vaade. Üldse. Siin ei peagi keegi olema logitud. Siis, Ee,
Õpetaja: üheksasada Nii,
Õpetaja: aga Kindlasti hakkas alati uudiste, kes võib pleegitada
Õpetaja: kõrvale siis ma arvan, et oluliselt
Õpetaja: Kas ilus
Õpetaja: pudel ei ole?
Õpetaja: Kuule, hindma ja pikku aeg, onju
Õpetaja: Salajane ka.
Õpetaja: Mis mõttes ma pidin ostma selle eraldi koos selle koodiga seda.
Õpetaja: Vabandust, nii et saab proovu sellist leha.
Õpetaja: Nii naljakas ma olen,
Õpetaja: See on
Õpetaja: kõik, näed ka, eksole?
Õpetaja: Aga lihtsalt. Ee.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: see. See üks puhul tuleb nii väga hea.
Õpetaja: Nii negatiiv.
Õpetaja: Ilmselt mängida mänginud.
Õpetaja: Huvitav, Kui vajutan seal, siis seal saab kiipude jagada.
Õpetaja: Paned peale.
Õpetaja: Oled veel suutnud?
Õpetaja: No nostalgia proovida.
Õpetaja: Elu Seal on kakssada kuusteist.
Õpetaja: Mul on ühe Kulla, väga uhke. Söö, mingi mäng käib ka. Jah, vahel arvutis. Jah,
Õpetaja: nii mõtlen.
Õpetaja: Mm,
Õpetaja: pane kolme, tulla et loobunud.
Õpetaja: Nad on
Õpetaja: Aa, jah, Ta on liiga hetkeline. Vaata, see saab õige huvi.
Õpetaja: Mm,
Õpetaja: ei ole võimalikult Kohutavalt siis ma mõtlesin kõige.
Õpetaja: Ee, Jah, nostalgia. Ei, värk on
Õpetaja: Praegu
Õpetaja: tavaliselt. Noh, tavaliselt mingi kaks, kakskümmend, Ee, nelisada,
Õpetaja: aga, noh, siis su ee arvutiselts hakkab olema mingi üliaeglane.
Õpetaja: Kaasa See on see ühe Lõigu kohvriga. Jah,
Õpetaja: Jumal, et see on väga proovinud
Õpetaja: teistatus metsa asi.
Õpetaja: Oi, Oi, oi, kus see on? Mingi samas kõrval, kohe osake.
Õpetaja: Aa, Minu Pizza juht.
Õpetaja: Palju sealt see slaid maksab? Aa, sama vist. Davai.
Õpetaja: No aga ilmselt garanteerides on selline mõnus soe. Jah, lähme, käisime vahel Vahel käitumine soe kuu juust. Sügav miljonit
Õpetaja: on väga hea.
Õpetaja: Mhmh,
Õpetaja: jah,
Õpetaja: okei
Õpetaja: koos Okei,
Õpetaja: tänan.
Õpetaja: Mina pakend terapi.
Õpetaja: Okei?
Õpetaja: Jaa,
Õpetaja: jõuad.
Õpetaja: Aitäh, pigem, Aga
Õpetaja: üks poiss oli endal seal Sellepärast saavutada abiga rohke, eksole?
Õpetaja: Ka oma firma klientide üle edasi.
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja külma ka töökaaslane, võiks Ee,
Õpetaja: nurist, eksole? Et saada lõikama. Ja siis ta ütles mulle, ee, ära teha, vaadates
Õpetaja: Tegelikult te näete rahulikult peale. Tegelikult jah, siiamaani vä
Õpetaja: miljonit.
Õpetaja: Ma olen nagu ära
Õpetaja: ja helistada.
Õpetaja: Jõuab nii
Õpetaja: ja annab
Õpetaja: head rääkida.
Õpetaja: Ahah, ja ma nägin sõnumit ka, et ma ei ole kodus, paneks.
Õpetaja: Jaa, palun. Jah, ja mm. Võite sinna Marietavile Näiteks vä.
Õpetaja: Mm, aitäh teile.
Õpetaja: Aa,
Õpetaja: Jaa, see peakski olema.
Õpetaja: Kuskile sa said toimima selle Ja ma võtsin teie. Võtsin selle
Õpetaja: jube Raske on igaühes veel
Õpetaja: täidetakse.
Õpetaja: Ei, ma tahtsin sama kodus.
Õpetaja: Siis ma nädalavahetusel
Õpetaja: aga tahaks nagu, noh, Mingisugune päikesele. Ma nagu ette valmistavad. Aga nüüd ma nüüd üritangi rääkida seda
Õpetaja: jupi kaupa niiöelda siis
Õpetaja: kõrge.
Õpetaja: Aitäh,
Õpetaja: kohe.
Õpetaja: Pahandumine tõuseb.
Õpetaja: Kus see Ground on?
Õpetaja: Mäletate iga viga?
Õpetaja: Panen ta ära.
Õpetaja: Okei, aga Noh, vaata, Mul on nagu see, et ma kirjutan siia mitmesse,
Õpetaja: mis sa paned, Kui sa märgid ära, siis panid selle kontrol.
Õpetaja: Mm, selle parema jooksul.
Õpetaja: Ee, tegelt sai siit kuidagi.
Õpetaja: Noh, see ongi siuke pikalt Ee, endale Sellised.
Õpetaja: Jah, väga
Õpetaja: jah.
Õpetaja: No ma arvan Nii et mis struktuur või ei ole läheb loodusse ning kohe, palun,
Õpetaja: kuna ma arvan. Jah,
Õpetaja: üks Kolmandik Cv, kolmandik
Õpetaja: distants kohvi ära ja ma saan aru. Ma tavaliselt ise neid veidi üles. Et Nii, aga mis niimoodi?
Õpetaja: Ja aitäh, aga Sul sulle tuleb See sa oled.
Õpetaja: Ja,
Õpetaja: mhm.
Õpetaja: Keegi hoida seda püsti. Mul on vaja seda
Õpetaja: näha. Mis väljundub mul on? Vaja pildile saada Need väljundid, mis siin on,
Õpetaja: aitäh.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: ei,
Õpetaja: ma ei hakka see sisse andma. Ja.
Õpetaja: Ja. Siis.
Õpetaja: Kuule, ma sain töö, Ma sain aru Sisse peab proovima. Muidugi. Näe, sest lahendused on väga lihtne.
Õpetaja: Nii hästi.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt oled normaalne
Õpetaja: Natukene
Õpetaja: selles suhtes
Õpetaja: kõrval.
Õpetaja: Mm täpselt
Õpetaja: kõik. Hästi. Teeme praegu Ahah, okei.
Õpetaja: Mis teie
Õpetaja: võõras keeles Ta
Õpetaja: ma unustanud.
Õpetaja: Viiskümmend kolm.
Õpetaja: Mm, sinuga meeldib.
Õpetaja: Hea küll, hakkame vaikselt. Ee, pihta
Õpetaja: Ee, panen siis Ee koordima Ka
Õpetaja: top recording et.